[Musique]
parra stickers bonjour pandore nous vous
recevons pour une chaîne intérêts qui
s'appelle singer view nous sommes en
direct est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succinctement oui je suis
professeur de philosophie politique à
l'université à bordeaux
c'est tout oui ce jeudi c'est déjà pas
mal et ça m'occupe beaucoup c'est tout à
fait content de vous recevoir on va
prendre le temps de discuter des
répercussions de la crise du coup vite
sur l'homme et
les réactions des différentes castes que
nos sociétés peut comprendre
s'ils sont sécessionnistes pas
sécessionnistes démissionnaire pas
démissionné
qu'est ce que vous pensez de la position
des élites face au capitalisme qu'il est
en train d'agoniser
le capitalisme est en train d'agoniser
je sais parce qu'il capitalisme est en
train d'agoniser ça j'en suis pas sûr du
tout pourquoi parce que pour l'instant
on n'est pas passé à un autre type
d'économie
donc voilà on peut pas avoir décrété la
l'agonie dire l'agonie du capitalisme
c'est dire que qu' il est en train de
finir et que bientôt il sera à l'isra
mort et
c'est qu'on s'en réjouisse ou qu'on s'en
inquiète c'est pas le cas enfin pas à
mes yeux pour l'instant j'ai pas vu de
signes cliniques qu'il était en train de
mourir
donc ça c'est premier prix la cavalerie
des banques centrales des injections de
liquidités massives à dossier aucun de
leurs techniques si on me dit qu'il ya
une crise financière
qui a des crises financières qui a des
cycles de crise financière récurrent
depuis fort longtemps et c'est bien sûr
mais de là à dire que parce qu'il ya une
crise en 2008 parce qu'on en a une autre
qui se prépare en ce moment et c'est le
capitalisme est finie non mais la
première partie de votre question
portait sur les élites
déjà le terme d'élite est compliqué yma
ces cours les lits les élites c'est pas
trop il m'arrive d'utiliser ce terme
j'ai toujours du mal à les en
l'utilisant je me dis toujours que c'est
vraiment un terme qui va pas
parce que c'est un terreau normatif qui
qui qui est une valorisation dire jeu
par un tueur d'élite chez quelqu'un qui
tire très bien quoi un des élites
sociales c'est une manière de dire des
gens qui ont une valeur supérieure donc
le terme déjà va pas même si je
comprends que vous l'utilisiez il
m'arrive mais aussi d'utiliser faute de
mieux si on veut dire les classes les
plus favorisées de la société
alors là évidemment il ya
tous les problèmes commencent parce que
dans les classes les plus favorisées la
société ya beaucoup de gens différents
par exemple dans les classes les plus
favorisées de la société il peut y avoir
des milliardaires qui ont qui vivent
totalement en dehors de toute vision
républicaine mais il peut y avoir aussi
des stars il peut y avoir des des des
grands médecins il peut y avoir des
grands juristes il peut y avoir rarement
voilà et donc c'est compliqué c'est une
catégorie qui est
qui est très très floue en fait comment
quand
est ce que vous voulez une sécession de
déclassement du
oui ce terme c'est ce thème de la
sécession des élites est pas nouveau il
a été popularisé notamment par
christopher lasch aux états unis il ya
longtemps déjà
bon c'est une vraie question
la question se pose
mais il faut là il faut l'instruire à
mon avis de manière
à chaque fois localisés dans des pays on
parle de sécession par rapport à quoi
par exemple en france
moi je pense qu'il faut poser la
question par rapport à un projet
républicain par rapport à un projet
républicain dans lequel nous sommes
toujours que ça nous plaise ou non il ya
un arrière-plan républicains à nos
institutions et à notre droit
on pourra décliner de plein de manières
sur l'éducation sur la santé etc etc je
ne dis pas forcément qu'il faut y
adhérer ou qu'il faut s'en détourner
mais c'est un fait et pour moi il est
clair que les catégories une partie des
catégories les plus aisées
financièrement et une partie du
personnel politique et de l'élite dans
ce sens là effectivement est en train de
détruire cette ce projet républicain
politique c'est choisir dessein
le terme de personnel politique non
c'est un terme que je prends comme ça
faute de mieux disons que normalement il
s'agit de nos représentants mais de fait
il s'agit de moins en moins de nos
représentants et de plus en plus ils
s'auto désignent comme dirigeant
donc c'est difficile de les appeler de
nos représentants politiques vous voyez
nous doute prochaines zones et
les deux prochaines je ne peux pas vous
dire mon
on attention à fx et sur celle qui vient
l'année qui vient il ya un an on a un an
on a une élection présidentielle au bout
d'un an du même coup il m'est très
difficile de me projeter au delà
l'année là qui se prépare est qu'ils se
disent qu'ils qui commence est décisive
est-ce qu'on va est ce qu'on va
comment vous poser cette question
là on est encore en apesanteur avant
l'élection présidentielle avec les
subsides de l'état est déversée pour
pouvoir
amortir la crise du coup vite déjà d'une
est-ce que vous pensez que après
l'élection présidentielle qui que ce
soit soit élu ça va commencer à
serrer la ceinture taper dans le lard et
avant une politique d'austérité comme on
a toujours mangé alors je pense que la
question non seulement commencera avant
mais qu'elle a déjà commencé puisque ce
que le gouvernement français est en
train de faire est proprement
catastrophique et en fait c'est un
scandale ce que le gouvernement est en
train de faire c'est en prenant des
mesures dont le caractère sanitaire
n'est absolument pas démontré douze
jours séparent fermés un petit magasin
qui reçoit
très peu de gens chaque jour dans des
régions où il n'y a pas de circulation
du virus par exemple à prendre un
exemple grotesque et caricatural le
caractère sanitaire de la mesure n'est
absolument pas établi je travaille même
avec des gens en santé publique qui sont
bien qualifiées par rapport à ces
questions parce qu'ils ont une très
longue expérience qui me disent très
tranquillement qu'il s'agit absolument
pas de mesures sanitaires mais de
mesures à la con je cite donc on appelle
ça des mesures sanitaires il faut
regarder interdire que mille personnes
se réunissent dans un dans un
amphithéâtre tout le monde peut entendre
que c'est une mesure sanitaire en ce
moment ça peut s'entendre sa part est
frappé au coin du bon sens et beaucoup
de
spécialiste de ces questions vont être
d'accord avec ça en revanche encore une
fois quand je reviens à mon exemple
fermer un commerce dans un village dans
lequel n'y a pas de circulation virale
pour quelqu'un qui reçoit 20 à 30
personnes etc non ce n'est pas une
mesure sanitaire française
il connaît le l'inertie de notre et un
sas est prouvé dans le passé si je vais
je me faire l'avocat du diable par
rapport à ces mesures sanitaires dans la
creuse un petit commerce qui peut pas
recevoir du public
comme on n'avait pas de masque on
n'avait pas de tests qu'on n'est pas
capable au népal et réactif on n'avait
pas les machines calibre au départ les
taaf et qui peu plus loin c'est à dire
que l'on n'a pas c'est la même règle
pour tout le monde et on en connaît le
raisonnement mais je veux finir mon
propos donc pour des mesures dont le
caractère sanitaire n'est absolument pas
établi pour dire les choses de cette
manière minimale au même moment on va
distribuer de l'argent public qui a été
levée sur les contributions un citoyen
voilà on distribue en fait cet argent de
manière complètement inconsidérées il
s'agit de en fait on est en train de
dilapider
l'argent public de même qu'on est en
train de dilapider
les ressources de l'assurance maladie et
c est de cette manière on ce qu'est ce
qui est fait c'est une mise en scène
d'une politique de santé complètement
exceptionnel avec une dépense
considérable avec du des millions de
tests qui sont dus des milliards et des
millions dans tout ça est toujours dans
une espèce de politique du chiffre avec
aucune stratégie tout le monde sera
d'accord y'a pas de stratégie c'est
n'importe quoi c'est essentiellement du
chiffre et de l'image donc on dilapide
des millions des millions et ont par
ailleurs on achète le silence de
millions de citoyens en les arrosant
d'argent au point de les mettre pour
certains vraiment dans une situation
mallet en a beaucoup qui m'ont dit dans
une situation de de mal être profond de
recevoir sur son compte en banque tous
les mois dix mille euros alors qu on
travaille pas et c'est absurde on
devrait travailler et qu'on sait très
bien que c'est la contribution qu'ils
public qui paye cette gabegie
c'est une catastrophe alors nous avons
déjà tous entendu si on lit un tout
petit peu la presse etc bruno le maire
nous expliquer que étant donné que ben
les caisses sont vides il va falloir
faire des efforts et il va falloir
entrer maintenant dans une austérité
pour bien plus bien plus grandes que
celles qui étaient déjà annoncés bien
plus grand pour éponger toutes ces
dépenses que distille ils ont été
obligés de faire donc la question elle
est déjà posé la question de la dette va
être une des grandes questions de
des élections
présidentielles et le discours de
l'autre de l'austérité va être
évidemment complètement déchaînée sur la
base de ces arguments donc en fait en
gros on a affaire à des à un
gouvernement qui
dilapide l'argent public et qui
déséquilibre tous les comptes et qui une
fois qu'il aura rendu tous les comptes
qui est déjà fait complètement malade
dira écoutez il faut passer à autre
chose il faut il faut passer à un autre
système si c'est pas ça qu'est-ce qui se
passerait est ce que est ce que cette
subornation veut tout cette subornation
contribuables on arrose ou de subsides
étatiques prix puis sur vos futures
notre futur engagement d'autres futures
est-ce que c'est aussi une façon de
mettre sous prozac la population pour
éviter que la population demande des
comptes avant la prise moi je sais pas
je peux pas vous dire ce que ferait les
gens s'ils étaient dans l'incapacité de
payer leurs loyers etc enfin des gens
qui sont des artisans des commerçants
installés 6 et s il en était là et c'est
je le rappelle le cas de certains
d'entre eux mais faut le rappeler mais
d'autres sont effectivement
subventionnés en fait part par un état
qui est devenu complètement fou et qui
effectivement achète une forme de
science mais effectivement quand vous
dites l'état c'est quoi c'est la
fonction publique ou de fonction
publique
qui se planquent depuis 40 ans dans des
postes grassement payés qui n'a jamais
été mis sous des situations outre que le
ronron quotidien
ou c'est l'appareil politique c'est une
très bonne question c'est très dur de
savoir ce qu'est l'état en fait qui est
l'état
qui représente l'état c'est pas si
simple en fait comme question
avec le néolibéralisme
on a un état qui organise la destruction
de l'état oui c'est une chose de cette
heure donc c'est très compliqué parce
qu'on sait plus qui est dans l'état qui
est en dehors qui et pour qui est contre
vous dire la transformation exactement
ça s'appelle la transformation de l'état
dans le langage du néolibéralisme mais
du même coup ça perturbe tout puisqu'on
ne sait plus qui est dans l'état qui est
content et c'est pour ça que depuis 30
ou 40 ans beaucoup de gens croient que
on a affaire à des politiques qui sont
pas néo libérale parce qu'elles se font
dans le cadre de l'état c'est la naïveté
que beaucoup à commencer par michel
foucault mais beaucoup d'autres ont
suivi et j'ai contribué à ma manière
a fini par déconstruire c'est que en
fait le néolibéralisme qui ce qui ce qui
s'élabore dans les années 30 c'est à une
c'est le fait d'imposer les normes du
marché depuis l'état à l'intérieur de
l'état et par l'état je voudrais encore
fait
qu'est ce qu'on fait
alors ça aussi c'est une question qu'on
me pose sans cesse et c'est aussi une
très bonne question la fameuse question
que faire
pour ce qui me concerne
je m'en suis expliquée dans un dans un
petit livre
qui s'appelle du capot grève que j'ai
publié à
au moment du premier confinement quand
je les écris le confinement je l'avais
pas prévu donc j'ai réécrit au dernier
moment pour pour parler de du
confinement j'ai mis une postface
s'appelle la grève confiné
cette question a été là qu est le fil
conducteur de ce livre c'était la
question de le faire pas seulement le
livre d'avant il faut s'adapter c'était
donc là la critique par par le
pragmatisme américain du néolibéralisme
et donc c'était une vision globale pas
seulement des directions global mais
très concrètement qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire là où on est ici et maintenant
dans un environnement aussi destructeur
aussi toxiques et donc je fais le récit
dans ce petit livre de
de ce que j'ai vécu à bordeaux
essentiellement à bordeaux pendant un an
sur le front de la mobilisation et sur
ce que ce qu'on a essayé de faire
puisque je n'étais pas tout seul ce
qu'on a essayé
et je reste convaincu quand je le
défends dans ce livre que pour faire
quelque chose il faut déjà penser ce
qu'on fait là où on est là où on se
trouve par exemple à bordeaux à nantes à
londres peu importe quelque part ou à
guéret qu'elle là où on est là où de
fait on vit là où on passe son temps
c'est là qu'il faut déjà penser ce qu'on
fait et au moment où on parle c'est à
dire maintenant et qu'il ya quelque
chose qui handicape complètement
l'action qui est de toujours se projeter
sur un plan strictement mondial
global et plus tard dans un avec un
corps un un horizon à venir qui en fait
et qui paralysent l'action donc je pense
qu'il faut déjà partir de ce qu'on fait
de là où on est et réfléchir aujourd'hui
demain matin et c'est premièrement
deuxièmement qu'il faut le faire en
essayant de ne pas être seul mais en
étant quelques-uns et ont je pense que
notre première tâche c'est de trouver
des complices des points d'appui des
gens avec lesquels on peut fonctionner
qui sont des vrais camarades de lutte
avec lesquels on peut agir voilà qu'on
très concrètement sur des choses très
précises
évidemment typiquement dans le cadre du
travail mais pas seulement on peut le
faire en tant que parent d'élève on peut
le faire en tant que citoyen d'une
mairie peu importe là on se trouve dans
la vie sociale ça je pense que c'est
essentiel mais pour autant cela ne
signifie pas que c'est un repli sur une
espèce de repli modeste
sur la vie locale et c'est absolument
pas une logique de colibri que je
dénonce
je dénonce absolument la logique colibri
or la logique du colibri c'est celle qui
est porté par beaucoup d'écologistes qui
est de dire n'entrons pas dans des
grands conflits clivant politique mais
revenons aux petits gestes c'est à dire
que si on utilise un peu moins tous
l'eau du robinet si on va un peu moins
tous acheté des produits chimiques et un
petit à petit
finalement toutes ces interactions
sociales cumulées nous irons vers le
vers un monde meilleur ce qui en fait
une vision libérale
c'est à dire les individus chacun dans
leur coin en faisant un peu mieux vont
permettre d'arriver
d'arriver vers le bien donc c'est pas du
tout mon point de vue moi j'ai une
vision résolument politique et donc avec
une part d'affrontements conflictuelle
c'est à dire chaque chaque lieu est un
champ de force et on n'est pas forcément
d'accord les uns avec les autres il faut
assumer nos conflits et donc il ya du
conflit mais avant d'envisager des
grands conflits
du type nous allons nous attaquer à au
grand capitalisme mondial en faisant un
plan révolutionnaire pour à la fin les
battre je pense que il faut pas oublier
j'essaie de montrer tout à l'heure on
est complètement hanté par cette manière
de faire tous même ceux qui se moquent
du socialisme révolutionnaire on a gardé
ses schèmes de temporalité à sion
de plus tard le grand moment où on y
arrivera et où ce sera mon prendra le
pouvoir ce sera le moment où on pourra
enfin dire ce qu'on a à dire
quand on écoute ça s'est jamais le
moment de lutter et s'est jamais
l'endroit donc moi je dit revenons à là
où on est
et pour se donner un exemple moi c'est
là en ce moment c'est à l'université là
où je me trouve c'est là qu'est la lutte
là ici maintenant et pas ailleurs
ça ne veut pas dire pour autant est ce
là où je me dis je me distingue
absolument du discours de certains
écologistes type colibri ça ne veut
absolument pas dire que
je me restreins à la petite forme aux
petits gestes au minimalisme pas du tout
il faut garder
absolument en tête des autres échelles
et par exemple l'échelle nationale
avec les élections présidentielles qui
est quelque chose de fondamental dans
lequel il faut il faut s'engager
il faut s'engager soit pour refuser le
vote soit pour empêcher la tenue des
élections soit pour voter pour machin
soit pour voter pour truc soit pour
dézinguer bidule peu importe mais il
s'agit pas quand je dis que la lutte se
passe ici et maintenant c'est pas pour
dire on abandonne donc la vision
nationale et c'est encore moi pour dire
qu'on n'a pas une vision globale un
mondialisé de ce qui se passe bien
entendu qu'il faut avoir une ensemble
essayer d'élaborer une lecture des des
logiques international lecture belgique
internationale
alors moi je m'intéresse à deux choses
sur lesquelles je suis vraiment peu
compétente mais c'est pour moi les deux
urgences
j'ai envie de mieux comprendre
la fascination
des chroniqueurs et compagnie
aujourd'hui pour la chine
bah c'est à dire les gens qui vous
explique un peu ce qu'il faut penser
aujourd'hui qu'ils sont qui s'il est
perdu tout lissine des éditoriaux qui
kibaki qui nous explique en gros ce
qu'il convient de penser quand on est
raisonnable on a effectivement une
partie d'entre eux pas tous pas tous
mais une partie d'entre eux qui s'est
déporté du modèle américain vers le
modèle chinois depuis longtemps depuis
les années 2000 déjà pour tunis eh ben
ça m'intéresse de d'essayer de
comprendre sa d'essayer de comprendre
comment ça marche d'essayer de
comprendre aussi ce que porte la
cheville ou
je sais pas c'est compliqué en tout cas
ça m'intéresse d'essayer de comprendre
ça et en ayant bien en tête que tout le
monde ne s'est pas reportée vers le
modèle chinois mais en tout cas dans le
tous ceux qui ont pignon sur rue qui
maquille petit qui articule un discours
qui est très écouté dans ses serres en
tout cas ça ça existe et ça a été très
puissant au
dans le cadre de la de l'épidémie où la
chine a été sans arrêt
montrer comme le modèle je le raconte
dans le petit tract
on résout dans sa gestion de l'épidémie
a pour moi clairement à tort
pourquoi parce que je vous expliquerai
apprécié au lait bien ce que je dis
toujours un prêt demain je vous promets
et donc il ya ça qui m'intéresse d'un
côté mais qui me paraît un peu
vertigineux parce que je ne lis pas le
chinois
je ne lis pas le chinois et j'ai pas
l'intention de m'y mettre parce que j'ai
d'autres urgences donc déjà ça va être
extrêmement compliqué de comprendre ce
que la chine veut faire même si là je
commence à lire des choses etc je ne
comprends pas forcément ça ça va être
difficile mais là où j'ai plus de moyens
de comprendre c'est ce qui se passe aux
etats unis effectivement le le le
là le passage de trump hayden ça vient
compliquer un peu les choses
avec la question du new deal la question
de la planification qui est en train de
redevenir une forme de normes
bon ça perturbe beaucoup de choses donc
moi ce qui m'intéresse et ans et depuis
l'europe je vais pas penser depuis autre
chose puisque je suis en europe je suis
européenne depuis le lieu que j'occupe
et de regarder un peu les influences en
fait la concurrence des influences entre
la chine et les états unis sur nous
voilà ça ça m'intéresse énormément sur
le plan international entre autres
choses
voilà ce que je pouvais vous dire après
sur le votre question sur la machine
reviendra sur machine après
sur sur le
sur la finance
l'extraterritorialité de la finance
c'était un parallèle faisons pression
sur certains états pour pouvoir avoir
des efforts pour avoir des choses comme
ça
est-ce que vous avez étudié ça cependant
de la lpr classe financière non je
connais ça a très mal dans ce qui va se
taper des pépés à saint barth ou turquie
qui secoue ce des choses comme ça non je
connais ça très mal enfin je connais
comme quelques personnes qui
s'intéressent à ces questions comme
citoyenne inquiète de tout ça évidemment
je connais des choses mais je n'ai pas
j'en ai pas fait pour l'instant l'objet
de mes recherches à aucun moment vie
ont-ils cru ce type de bd ou font des
commandes et puis par ailleurs je suis
pas sûr soit un état vous dites un état
financier je sais pas je sais pas un
monde peut-être si vous deviez infiltré
le pur que sinon sur vous faire vers
chez moi j'suis pas dans mes projets
non j'ai un filtre d'autres choses
j'ai un filtre en ce moment j'ai un
filtre le chu ça ça c'est plus dans mes
cordes et qu'est ce que vous faites en
infiltration et bunge en fait je regarde
comment fonctionne l'hôpital un hôpital
comme un chu français de l'intérieur
c'est très intéressant
comment que je vais sur place en fait je
passe du temps dans les murs de
l'hôpital
voilà je travaille avec des hospitaliers
j'ai évidemment des points d'appui des
gens extrêmement précieux avec moi pour
le faire
mais
voilà ça oui ça c'est tout à fait ça
m'intéresse puisqu'en fait ça
m'intéresse parce qu en fait j'y tiens
au chu donc j'ai envie qu'ils continuent
à exister j'ai envie de le défendre et
donc à les infiltrer pour reprendre
votre formule c'est pas vraiment le mot
mais on peut jouer sur les mots à les
infiltrer ce milieu qui est un milieu
difficile un très très difficile dans
lequel il ya des rapports de pouvoirs
terribles et c'est donc c'est pas facile
mais allez allez dans ce milieu là oui
ça me ça m'intéresse parce que c'est un
milieu que j'ai envie dans lequel j'ai
envie de
ba de
contribuer à aider dans avec mes faibles
moyens les gens qui sont allés renforcer
en fait donc là ça a du sens mais je
vais pas à les infiltrer comme espionne
les financiers à samart je suis désolé
de dire du centre dit de faire attention
pas frotter votre micro avec votre coude
et revenons à la chine
revenons à la chine
est-ce que ça a été le bon modèle de
gestion des épidémies a bien sûr que
nous en faites pas pour plusieurs
raisons d'abord pour pour commencer ces
deux là semble-t-il que la chose est
parti du fait
de
bruno cordier de dégradation
catastrophique de l'environnement qui
ont favorisé des zoonoses et c'est pas
que la preuve c'est pas la première fois
et ce n'est pas la dernière hausse avant
cette théorie aussi en apesanteur mme
banon nous savons d'ores et déjà que
la manière dont les chinois traite les
élevages intensifs la manière dont ils
traitent les zones de coexistence entre
entre les milieux sauvages et les
milieux urbanisés
constitua ni de zoonoses c'est pas une
nouveauté c'est pas seulement les
chinois c'est d'autres pays bien entendu
même en europe la question se pose en
europe aussi dans nos élevages intensifs
la question se pose tous les
vétérinaires le savent donc mais en asie
c'est extrêmement fort et en chine tout
particulièrement non mais juge que je
poursuis donc à partir de là le la zone
aux elle est venue semble-t-il de la
donc déjà il ya un premier problème il
n'y a eu aucune réponse des chinois pour
dire effectivement il ya quelque chose
qui va pas dans nos élevages est quelque
chose qui va pas avec nos animaux
exotiques con con n'importe dans dans la
cuisine et dans les intérieurs des des
foyers donc tout ça ça va pas il ya eu
rien du tout et en plus il ya eu par
rapport à l' enquête de l'om est
carrément des dissimulations et c'est
donc déjà sur les causes du coït 19
déjà c'est une pure catastrophe érigé ce
pays en modèle c'est incroyable ensuite
sur la manière dont les choses ont été
prise en main est bien d'abord dans un
premier temps je vous rappelle ce sont
les citoyens chinois qui sur les réseaux
sociaux on dit c'est une catastrophe qui
est en train de se produire à one il
faut absolument agir et comme vous le
savez il ya eu des mesures de répression
très graves contre les lanceurs d'alerté
donc là encore présenter ça comme un
modèle c'est quand même incroyable enfin
quand la chine s'est enfin emparée du
problème elle a mis en place parce que
c'est un régime
absolument autoritaire des mesures que
jamais dans un pays libre on aurait dû
accepter et ensuite nous avons suivi tes
l'italie à imiter nous avons limité
l'italie qu'imiter la chine et on a
annoncé me à faire la même chose
ce qui est complètement fou c'est à dire
à enfermer les gens
et c'est
donc non érigé cela en modèle c'est pas
possible ça veut dire que ça voudrait
dire que pour traiter un virus
respiratoires il faudrait annuler la
démocratie bien sûr que non la
démocratie c'est pas un épiphénomène
historique
un épiphénomène historique
sais pas ce que ça veut dire un
épiphénomène historique et puis
choisissez un épiphénomène et c'est pas
historique soit c'est un phénomène
historique mais il ya quelque chose de
contradictoire dans votre formule c'est
fait exprès
un épiphénomène basée en fait sur ultra
consommation énergétique c'est à dire
plus on peut consommer plus les gens
sont libres du plus les gens peuvent je
vais être vulgaire mais péter dans la
soie
ou lancer des grandes campagnes de
guerre et j'en passe et des meilleurs
pour aller chercher d'autres sources
pour continuer cette pseudo démocratie
des dons comme notre capacité à
consommer des ressources va baisser est
ce que cette
démocratie établie va être amiens
péricliter
en fait vous me disiez est un bon modèle
pour faire fonctionner mais vous de
l'élevage en batterie de l'homme ont dit
plusieurs choses vous me dites que c'est
une pseudo démocratie
ou alors vous dites c'est une démocratie
donc la première question à savoir si
nous sommes dans une démocratie oui ou
non
c'est pas clair
dans la mesure où
en fait on est ça a été largement dit
par d'autres chercheurs bien avant moi
plutôt dans un gouvernement
représentatif
le gouvernement représentatif il a été
théorisée à la fin du xviiie siècle aux
états unis et en france et c'est par des
gens qui étaient hostiles à la
démocratie qu'est ce que c'est la
théorie du de gouvernement représentatif
qui est portée aux états unis par
quelqu'un comme hamilton au madison qui
sont des antidémocrates
le gouvernement représentatif c'est
l'idée que
effectivement il va falloir porter la
voix du peuple il ya cette référence au
peuple mais le peuple lui-même en est
parfaitement incapable donc il faut
dégager une élite justement d'élus qui
sont les gens compétents qui
sont les seuls habilités à diriger
ça va passer par des mécanismes de
manière extrêmement cohérente
d'élections puisque pour être élu il
faut être élu donc il faut des élections
et les élections vont permettre de
dégager les meilleurs ceux qui
s'opposent à la plèbe à aux classes
populaires jugé inapte irrationnelle
incompétente donc nous sommes dans un
actuellement dans un gouvernement
représentatif et les théoriciens du
gouvernement retraite représentatif je
vous renvoie par exemple à hao textent
très précis sur le sujet très historique
de bernard manon bernard manin qui est
très connu aux états unis chercheurs
français
et qui trouve d'ailleurs trouve ça très
bien bernard manin le gouvernement
représentatif ça lui va parfaitement
il explique très bien que les partisans
du gouvernement représentatif sont anti
démocrate parce qu'en fait pour des gens
comme bernard manin ces théoriciens en
raison parce qu'en fait la démocratie
est impossible parce que de fait les
classes populaires sont incapables de
prendre les rênes d'un pays elles aussi
elles le font c'est une catastrophe donc
en fait on se trouve dans un système
comme ça depuis le 19e siècle en fait le
gouvernement représentatif avance ses
pions contre la monarchie par exemple
contre le régime monarchique et il le
fait de plus en plus en se drapant dans
le temps de la démocratie mais c'en est
pas une
nous
disons que le terme de démocratie a été
on le voit très bien chez walter
lippmann que j'ai étudié
il utilise le terme de démocratie pour
détruire la démocratie
dépendant démocratie et est ce que le
slogan que nous invendus des pains
d'épicés domaine pour revenir à notre
capacité de consommation énergétique
c'est à dire que est-ce qu'on va se
retrouver à adapter un adopter un autre
système une théocratie
dictature qu'elle est lié à de nouveaux
winkel et là le modèle le plus adapté
pour gérer l'élevage en batterie de
l'être humain
est ce qu'il faut et un kaiser à la tête
de dictature la plus dure qui va
permettre d'être fonctionnel alors
fonctionner pour aller chercher quoi
fonctionnel pour faire quoi ça ça reste
la question
mais est-ce que c'est pas la démocratie
c'est pas un truc de beatniks
un truc l'habite de bi poin toutes deux
jours pas sérieux en fin de compte donc
là l'autre question c'est est ce que
c'est possible
écoutez je sais pas en fait je ne sais
pas ce qui va se passer plus tard j'en
sais rien du tout je vous dis juste que
de fait
la manière dont nous fonctionnons elle
est anti démocratique
on sait
on a beaucoup entendu que le mode de
gouvernement d'encadrer t était
démocratique essayer de montrer en quoi
dénoncer tout à fait discutable ce qui
est nouveau c'est que maintenant la
remise en cause de la démocratie par les
dirigeants par les chroniqueurs qui ont
qui sont considérés comme ayant une
parole raisonnable et c est de plus en
plus bas tandis c'est de plus en plus
normal dénoncé tranquillement sur un
plateau que la démocratie est un
problème que
ça marche pas que ça nous conduit au
populisme et c'est donc en fait le
prestige idéologique dont a pu
bénéficier la démocratie entre 1945 et
aujourd'hui est en train de s'effondrer
depuis le début des années 2000 et de
fait depuis que les corps électoraux
commencent à refuser par exemple la
politique européenne les la
mondialisation dans certains pays et
c'est donc depuis que
le corps électoral temps à refuser ce
qui est prétend prétend présenté comme
irréversible comme l'unique voie depuis
on entend de plus en plus ce discours
que la démocratie c'est trop compliqué
il faut passer à autre chose la chine
s'en sort quand même très bien l'asie
c'est vraiment pas mal c'est vraiment
quand même des pays modèles où il ya un
vrai sens du collectif où il ya une
vraie croissance etc etc donc oui la
démocratie est de plus en plus remise en
cause par ce que vous appelez les élites
revenons renoue phénomène de cour de des
chroniqueurs télé de plateau patentés
c'est quoi ces du suivisme ccc de
l'attitude parasitaire c'est à dire que
comme il en mange c'est toujours plus
sympa de suivre la vague c c est une
réelle prise de position personnelle
c'est quoi c'est alors c'est très
compliqué de faire l'analyse de ces
motifs moi ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que j'ai à faire à pas mal de
journalistes depuis deux ans c'est bon
courage
c'est quelque chose de tout à fait
nouveau pour moi puisque je connaissais
pas tout ça avant avant ya deux ans
j'ai beaucoup de gens je vois j'ai
rencontré beaucoup de gens j'ai beaucoup
de gens téléphonent et j'ai des
discussions très intéressantes c'est un
milieu qui souffrent beaucoup est ce que
me disent certains plein de gens très
sympas au téléphone avec lesquels je
m'entends parfaitement mais c'est qu'ils
n'ont pour beaucoup plus aucune liberté
en fait ils sont sous un contrôle
extrêmement dur des rédactions qui elles
mêmes sont sous le contrôle des
actionnaires etc donc c'est c'est
extrêmement compliqué et pour beaucoup
la question est de savoir si s'ils
veulent encore fonctionner à l'intérieur
s'il faut rester à l'intérieur et donc
filé droit par rapport à ceci ou cela en
attendant des jours meilleurs s'il faut
partir mais si on part on va où c'est
très compliqué
les mobiles des uns et des autres pour
pour se soumettre moi je vais pas me
lancer dans une analyse psychologique
mais en tout cas on est dans un moment
où les pressions à la soumission absolue
aux discours officiels sont extrêmement
fortes et c'est un mélange de soie de
censure directe soit d'autocensure soit
de mise à l'écart sur luxation va c'est
compliqué quels conseils vous avez donné
aux journalistes
moi j'ai pas toujours même chose c'est
que chacun là où ils se trouvent
se trouvent des alliés les gens qui la
confiance avec lesquels il se met voilà
ils constituent un réseau un petit
réseau de résistance un micro réseau de
résistance là où il se trouve pour
mettre en place des actions faire
péricliter s'il le faut des réunions
trouver des endroits de repli entre et
éventuellement relativement dans la
clandestinité en ayant des activités
médiatiques autres qui sont pas connues
avec un pseudo etc enfin il ya plein de
moyens de faire je dis pas que c'est
facile puisqu'on est dans un moment
terrifiant où toutes les institutions
sont en train d'être détruite par les
gens qui nous gouvernent
je pourrais vous donner plein d'exemples
mais c'est la seule voie c'est une
logique de résistance c'est-à-dire que
quand vous êtes face à un pouvoir qui
est dans un tel niveau de destruction et
d'oppression la seule logique que je
vois c'est la logique du réseau de
résistance on prend son vélo avoir
machin on et attention à pas être
écoutés on a des messages finalement
entre nous confidentiel on organise des
coûts ce que j'appelle du sabotage et on
ne peut pas faire autre chose et il faut
avancer masqué
question du petit arnaud sur internet
est ce que la convention citoyenne pour
le climat est un réel danger pour cette
politique représentative le début de
quelque chose pour interrogation j'en
doute j'en doute beaucoup mais j'ai
peut-être tort
j'ai peut-être tort parce que
effectivement ça leur a
le fait d'avoir essayé d'
instrumentaliser cette cette convention
citoyenne
ben c'est finalement ça a pas non plus
très bien marché pour eux dont bon mais
je ne suis pas convaincu que ce genre de
de pseudo à nouveau je reproche emploi
votre expression de d'expérience pseudo
démocratique parce que pour moi c'est
celle assez de la démo c'est une ans est
une une mise en scène de démocratie
participative
c'est une mise en scène de démocratie
participative pourquoi parce que tous
les gens qui sont là ont été
soigneusement triés sur le volet ils ont
été construites et ils ont été élus
square com considéré comme étant adoubé
comme pouvant siéger là et cerexhe donc
non la démocratie participative suppose
une certaine radicalité où on ne
contrôle pas les gens qui vont prendre
la parole on contrôle pas ce qui va se
passer là tout était déjà extrêmement
contrôlée et ça se veut de la démocratie
participative alors qu'en fait on est à
fond dans la logique de la
représentation et du gouvernement
représentatif
quel type de système vous envisagez
outre que celui ci est ce que c'est un
système dit théocratie dictature
qu'est-ce qui est le plus fonctionnel
dans les paramètres qu'on doit être à
nager
moi c'est très clair si vous avez
regardé mes travaux moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est l'hypothèse
démocratique voilà je trouve qu'avant de
la 2d col de la disqualifier il faudrait
essayer parce qu'on n'a jamais encore
fait dans nos pays à notre époque donc
il faut
c'est bon c'est mon hypothèse c'est une
hypothèse c'est pas c'est pas ma foi
c'est pas ma religion
c'est pas ça du tout ce dont il s'agit
c'est entre eux pas en démocratie comme
en religion c'est une hypothèse
exactement comme les scientifiques ont
des noms des hypothèses qu'il met à
l'épreuve voilà mon hypothèse c'est loin
d'être la seule à avoir cette hypothèse
qui en les choses encourageantes je
pense qu'il ya énormément de gens qui
sont attachés à cette hypothèse mon
hypothèse c'est le cdc de mettre en
place partout on est des fonctionnement
démocratique au travail à l'école à
l'université à l'hôpital partout et avec
toute la radicalité que ça implique
voilà c'est ça mon hypothèse hautain et
c'est pas un système c'est pas un
système puisque c'est pas du tout une
vision d'en haut du genre je suis une
intellectuelle après avoir beaucoup lu
pendant 25 ans voilà j'ai la vision pour
le monde entier qui est la suivante
voilà le système je vous donne mon
traité est appliqué pour moi ce type de
démarche est aberrante l'idée que parce
qu'on a lu pendant 25 ou 30 ans on a une
vision systématique qu'on va livrer au
monde c'est la vision de tout à l'heure
c'est à dire le monde
le monde d'après l'horizon qui va tout
changer c'est le rapport au temps dont
je parlais tout à l'heure comme
parfaitement délétère et qui vous fait
ne pas voir qu'en fait votre lutte elle
doit se mener ici maintenant avec les
gens qui sont là donc moi j'ai pas cette
vision là je la trouve grave et je pense
qu on est malheureusement encore hanté
par ce fantasme de d'une élite ou d'un
ensemble d'intellectuels ou d'un
ensemble de combattants qui qui vont
voir la lumière et nous dire d'en haut
ce qu'il faut faire je n'y crois pas un
instant par contre prenons l'hypothèse
dont on hérite hypothèse démocratique on
n'a pas inventé je n'ai pas inventé moi
même c'est un héritage prenons la
prenons aussi l'idée républicaine dont
j'avais également dont on hérite tous
moi j'ai envie de 2,2 voilà de faire
face à ces deux héritages de c2c idée
parce qu'il s'agit d'idées
l'idée républicaine idées démocratiques
et essayons de les mettre à l'épreuve de
voir jusqu'à quel point c'est possible
gestion avocat du diable de diaby ou sur
internet est ce que le chômage partiel
fait partie des dépenses dit lapidaire
que l'état de l'état qu'elle évoque
un
effet partie des dépenses dilapidant de
l'état qu'elle évoque ça dépend quand
vous mettez un chômage partiel
en chômage des gens au chômage vous
privez travail des gens pour un virus
respiratoires et que c'est absolument
justifié sur le plan sanitaire il faut
bien leur donner une indemnité
compensatoire ou un chômage ou quelque
chose donc c'est pas du tout là on n'est
pas du tout dans la logique de la
dilapidation
en revanche quand il s'agit de mesures
dont le caractère sanitaire n'a
absolument pas été démontrée là c'est
une gabegie effectivement là on revient
à ce que j'ai peur il faut toujours être
précis est situé pour regarder ce qui se
passe ici maintenant selon les contextes
voilà et là nous pouvons très facilement
documenté des gens peut-être s'y emploie
en ce moment je l'espère
a démontré en croisant avec une vision
de santé publique et une vision
économique des choses tout l'argent qui
est en train d'être
dilapidé et qui va permettre ensuite à
ce même gouvernement et à ses alliés qui
sont fort nombreux vous le savez ils se
disent parfois de gauche et se disent de
droite mais en fait ils sont
parfaitement alliés ils ont la même
vision qui vont pouvoir s'appuyer là
dessus pour dire plus que jamais il va
falloir faire des coupes à l'université
à l'hôpital par tous est entré dans une
austérité décuplée d'ailleurs je
rappelle que pour l'hôpital le budget de
l'année prochaine qui a été votée c'est
un budget d'austérité
voilà il suffit de regarder
ce qui a été voté
niveau de l'assemblée nationale donc oui
donc
c'est là qu'ils aillent à m'expliquer 5
on est encore en train de daf et bien
notre système de santé alors qu'on
rentre dans l'air le siècle des menaces
on rentre dans l'ère des épidémies gros
on arrive au moment de payer la facture
et on voit où on voit notre système qui
est encore mis à genoux c'est quoi c'est
une démarche intellectuelle qui n'a pas
évolué lui c'est des gens qui sont sur
les rails de leurs plans qui nous sont
qui doit être les fils pas c'est pour
faire plaisir à son supérieur n + 1
hiérarchie qui lui va faire plaisir à
son époux sa hiérarchie qu'un site 8 mai
c'est un mélange de tout ça
effectivement mais on se sont inversés
une vision du monde qui est complètement
disqualifié
dont on voit les effets catastrophiques
et ce qu'il apporte
ont décidé d'aller jusqu'au bout voilà
habitudes voilà et s'il n'y avait que le
problème c'est effectivement les
hiérarchies travail que vous évoquez et
qui en fait produisent des chaînes de
commandement enfin je vous donne un
énorme ce qui se passe à haut niveau du
gouvernement actuel a un effet sur la
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur et
de la recherche qui a décidé de détruire
tous les budgets de recherche de
l'université de geler tous les postes et
au moment plus que jamais on aurait
besoin de recherche on aurait besoin de
formation on aurait besoin de s'occuper
des étudiants qui sont dans l'état de
désespoir que vous savez au moment où on
aurait besoin de lieux démocratique pour
débattre de manière rationnelle et en se
tenant correctement sans s'invectiver
sans s'insulter de wes que nous allons
ce à quoi sert l'université entre autres
tout cela au même moment tous les
budgets sont voilà coupé violemment
le problème c'est que cela s'est relayée
par les présidents d'université
qui disent il faut couper alors dans
leur rhétorique ça s'appelle faire des
efforts donc vous avez les méritants qui
font des efforts c'est d'ailleurs c'est
ce qu'ils détruisent leur formation on
leur distribue des bons points en dix
ans bravo vous avez des deux fait des
efforts vous avez un esprit de
responsabilité vous travaillez pour
l'équité et la solidarité de notre
établissement et puis tous ceux qui
essaient de résister dont je fais partie
sont considérés comme des gens qui ne
font aucun effort
qui n'ont aucun sens qui n'ont aucun
sens qu'ils sont donc irresponsables qui
conduisent tout le monde à la
catastrophe par une vision radicaliser
extrémistes ce qui se passe alors ce qui
se passe dans ses dents dans
l'université je le répète c'est certes
un président de la république et sa
ministre mais c'est un c'est un ensemble
de tous les présidents d'université sont
pas comme ça mais malheureusement
beaucoup le sont un ensemble de
présidents d'université qui par ailleurs
ensuite vont appuyer sur des chefs des
sous-chefs et ces 15 ne sont pas des
chefs qui sont nos représentants
normalement il devrait nous représentées
puisqu'on est aussi sur un système
d'élection et qui en réalité en fait
participent à ce pouvoir et à cette
destruction de nos institutions par
l'austérité donc en fait c'est
effectivement le vrai problème c'est que
c'est pas seulement un gouvernement qui
est à l'heure c'est ce que vous disiez
tout à l'heure c'est toutes ces chaînes
de commandement qui sont innombrables
on fait comment pour combattre cette
prise de contrôle de la dialectique qui
a pour but de culpabiliser mais trop bon
ce qui ne marche pas dans la parole
universel que la république en marche ou
d août
vous distille et on fait comment pour
combattre cette prise de contrôle de
dialectique
cette prise de contrôle de direct de
dire 'voilà robin tu casses ton petit
travail tu fais des économies c'est bien
mais un bon j'ai bien
est-ce que c'est pas trop tard est-ce
que je vais être vulgaire encore mais
est-ce que les gens sont pas devenus
trop résignée trop content ou schumi
pour relever la tête et dire maintenant
mais c'est une finale
où ils ont trop peur
écoutez il faut pas trop se poser cette
question moi ce que je peux vous dire
c'est qu'il ya des millions de gens que
cette situation fait souffrir
que quand je fais des agnostiques je
suis absolument pas tout seul donc moi
c'est mon seul problème ici et
maintenant c'est de dire cela je ne suis
pas seul et je ne vois pas pourquoi nous
décréterions d'emblée que nous avons
perdu et c'est toujours la même angoisse
les gens ont peur de perdre il se
projette dans l'avenir ils veulent soit
une espèce de système à la fin comment
on va prendre le pouvoir etc mais s'il
voit pas s'il voit pas si on voit pas un
plan en fait qui nous mais voilà si on
peut pas se projeter dans une espèce
d'horizon
téléologique on aura gagné à la fin et
si on n'a pas des garanties et ben ça
paralyse les gens croient que c'est une
erreur il faut
et c'est là où il faut pas sombrer dans
le sacrificielle il s'agit pas de ce cru
si fier et c'est qu'il faut se protéger
faut être malin mais il faut lutter pied
à pied il devenir martyr non surtout pas
surtout pas surtout pas parce que c'est
précisément c'est précisément pas comme
ça que ça marche ça marche pas là aussi
c'est toujours les mêmes vieux chem
après le grand soir dans lequel tout le
monde se continue à se projeter après
une victoire assurée par un plan qui
serait déjà entièrement pensé il ya bien
sûr l'idée que si on lutte il faut se
sacrifier il faut le payer deux fois
c'est un vieux chais mme chrétien qui
imprègne le marxisme révolutionnaire
on a chez marx c'est vraiment l'idée que
le prolétariat et est un nouveau christ
et un agneau qui va falloir sacrifiés à
l'autel de l'histoire pour pour ensuite
se libérer non je pense que c'est une
erreur funeste et c'est une manière
toujours de se projeter dans un au delà
ça a été très très bien très bien montré
par par nietzsche dont je partage
absolument pas les options politiques
mais qui a très bien montré qu'il y
avait dans le socialisme révolutionnaire
une structure en fait qui est une
manière de temporiser qui vient du
christianisme avec un au-delà donc il
faut revenir ici et ici on a des choses
à sauver mois tous les matins j'ai des
étudiants en face de moi c'est à eux je
dois m'adresser je dois leur montrer que
je me comporte de manière responsable
c'est à dire que je refuse ces coupes je
refuse de collaborer avec un pouvoir qui
est destructeur et c'est déjà bien
d'avoir fait ça c'est déjà un acte
d'éducation voilà ils en font ce qu'ils
veulent mais voilà j'ai affaire à des
étudiants dont je suis responsable j'ai
des responsabilités même si elles sont
minuscules dans mon université et je
dois aller défendre la tête haute et je
dois me protéger avec les autres avec
lesquels je lutte et les protéger aussi
pour qu'on n'ait pas à en payer le prix
et on en est capable si vous voulez je
n'arrête pas de le répéter je suis
fonctionnaire d'état ça va comment
briser assez peu en fait parce que quand
on
se rend compte que on a fait dans pour
arriver là où j'en suis 15 ans d'études
ouais et qu'on peut ajouter trois ans
pour devenir professeur donc ça fait on
en est à 18 que ont très souvent ce qui
a été mon car on a fait un emprunt que
je traîne encore juste pour pouvoir se
loger à paris quand et c'est bon les
gens comme moi
à
25 ans d'ancienneté mais en fait moi
j'en ai plus parce que j'ai commencé
plus jeunes encore
c'est 3000 euros par mois et oui donc
3000 euros par mois vous vous doutez
bien que ces gens là peuvent pas se
loger à paris
même dans une ville comme bordeaux ou
dans des conditions lamentables voilà
pour peu qu'ils aient une famille avec
deux trois enfants dont ils savent même
pas où les mettre
quand on est dans une ville comme
bordeaux ou strasbourg etc c'est très
difficile habitait au centre-ville
la plupart on a on ad on a des dettes
des crédits on téléphone je veux faire
pleurer personne il ya des gens qui sont
dans des situations bien plus
catastrophiques mais c'est juste pour
comprendre que nous n'appartenons pas à
l'élite sociale au sens économique du
mot plus en tout cas parce que c'était
le cas avant elle et les universitaires
avaient un niveau de vie beaucoup plus
élevé que les classes moyennes enfin
plus élevé toi aujourd'hui il faut
savoir qu'un maître de conférences s'il
a pas d'ancienneté il commença à moins
de 2000 euros par mois
un maître de conférences qui s'est
battue pendant des années pour obtenir
un poste qu'il est extrêmement difficile
d'obtenir donc on a un niveau de
paupérisation de ce métier qui est
sidérant en revanche ce qu'on ce qu on a
encore ce que j'ai aujourd'hui c'est
peut-être pas garanti très longtemps
mais pour l'instant j'ai la garantie de
l'emploi
on peut pas le président de mon
université même si ce que je lui dise
que je raconte lui lui déplaît ne peut
pas mettre dehors demain matin ça c'est
vrai
c'est d'ailleurs vrai pour les
employeurs en général dans le droit du
travail mais ils ont les moyens de faire
craquer les gens c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué de mettre dehors un
fonctionnaire donc je trouve que déjà ça
quand on a ça au lycée partout quand on
est protégé par sa on doit s'en servir
c'est un devoir de se servir de ça
on peut pas dire ben oui mais je peux
pas parler parce que non c'est pas vrai
on va pas être mis à la rue demain matin
certes on va avoir des vexations on va
avoir des demandes de promotion qui vont
être bloqués mais on a le pouvoir de
défendre donc on n'est pas démuni
l'ensemble de ces gens qui sont attachés
à l'hypothèse démocratiques qui ont
envie d'essayer de comprendre ce que
c'est que l'idée républicaine enfin ce
que je disais qu'ils sont fort nombreux
il ya beaucoup d'entre eux beaucoup
d'entre eux ne sont pas entièrement
démunis ils peuvent quand même se se se
mobiliser est ce que vous connaissez le
reniement de saint pierre de charles
baudelaire
non alors ça termine par certes je
sortirai quant à moi satisfait d'un
monde où l'action n'est pas sûr du rêve
je n'oublie pas la fin c'est quoi votre
rêve
je suis assez peu rêveuse en fait
l'action là
je vais pas rêver non pas trop nous
qu'est ce que vous pouviez rêve de
vacances en grèce
agnico douce non
non non non je ne vois pas les choses en
terme de rêve en fait du tout
pourquoi parce que je vous dise et moi
ce qui m'intéresse c'est le réel en fait
la réalité la matérialité la précision
des choses je trouve ça passionnant en
fait j'aime j'aime sur l'essai comme les
dentellières qui font leurs dentelles
voilà j'aime la précision ou est ce
qu'on en a en fait je suis profondément
matérialiste
et j'aime regarder l'état des forces
réel du monde de tel qu il se trouve
l'arrière dans ton travail comment voilà
c'est ça qui me plaît et ce qui me plaît
c'est de transformer des stocks
contribue à transformer un état de faits
réels quoi donc vous nous parlez de vos
étudiants bonbons qui sont donc l état
sanitaire qu'elle est un financier qui
est un psycho logique l etat alors ça va
être très dur de vous répondre parce que
j'ai 300 étudiants et la plupart d'entre
eux ont purement et simplement disparu
ils ont disparu pour une raison très
simple qui est qu on les a mis dehors
on les a je vous ai parlé du logement à
bordeaux c'est extrêmement compliqué de
se loger à bordeaux ça coûte extrêmement
cher tous les signaux ont été envoyées
par notamment mon université qu'
il y aurait plus de cours il y aurait
plus de cours pendant le moment du
confinement mais au delà et c'est donc
tout a basculé dans
des contenus données par internet donc
forcément vous pouvez très bien
comprendre la plupart sont partis et
avec aucune garantie de revenir je sais
pas quand est-ce qu'ils vont revenir je
sais même pas s'ils vont revenir un jour
là pour l'instant la rentrée prochaine
on a aucun signal donné par notre
université
qu'une rentrée va être organisée et à la
place on a une
mise en scène pathétique d'enseignement
mais qu'il s'agit pas d'enseignements un
individu qui parle à sa caméra tout seul
c'est pas un cours ce n'est pas un cours
un court c'est une aventure collective
c'est une interaction c'est un groupe
qui part ensemble pendant plusieurs
semaines plusieurs mois pour travailler
une question et c'est une aventure
intellectuelle qu'on fait ensemble ce
n'est pas une connexion entre un
individu tout seul qui parle dans le
vide devant sa caméra et un autre
individu tout seul qui essaient de
régurgiter ensuite pour avoir une bonne
note ça c'est pas le court donc là on a
mis en scène toute une série de deux
dispositifs pseudo pédagogique qui sont
en fait un désastre là où je me réjouis
et je remercie vraiment les médias y
compris les médias dominants c'est
qu'ils ont extrait vraiment documenter
ce désastre ya pas eu un an article
depuis le mois de novembre dernier pour
dire que c'était bien les cours par zone
et c'est pas un seul par contre il y a
eu des tonnes de reportages télévision
d'articles dans tousles toutes les
revues pour dire c'était un désastre est
vraiment bravo là quelque chose a été
établi et là on a gagné quelque chose le
problème c'est que du côté des instances
vous voyez un terme un peu flou il n'y a
aucun signal pour demander un retour
aucune volonté pour que les étudiants
soient sur place j'ai dû me battre avec
quelques collègues extrêmement courageux
en plein hiver contre tout le monde pour
arriver à faire revenir les étudiants
j'ai réussi à récupérer une toute petite
partie c'est à dire ceux qui étaient
obligés de rester à bordeaux et qui
était complètement livrés à eux mêmes et
ils sont venus sur place et on a eu des
tout petits groupes qu'on a maintenu et
ils nous ont énormément remercier et il
me remercie encore d'avoir fait ça mais
voilà où on en est et ils m'ont ils nous
ont fait part soit de leur désarroi
personnel qui est vraiment immense soit
quand il était très honnête et qui
disait ben moi personnellement dans ma
vie en ce moment je vais relativement
bien donc je tiens de leur désarroi
collectif c'est-à-dire pour pour les
étudiants et pour l'université donc
l'université là est un champ de ruines
c'est cette année a détruit nos
universités qui était déjà très
fragilisée par des politiques de coupe
perpétuelle de par la misère dont je
vous ai parlé un par le fait que sans
parler de nos revenus mais nos
conditions de travail qui sont
complètement dégradée c'est un pas de
chauffeur mais le flou alors
effectivement cela absolument pas de
chauffage
donc on crève de froid
les locaux sont souvent c'est pas
forcément le cas par exemple de mon
couloir puisqu'il est en train d'être
il va être livré tout neuf flambant
neufs au mois de juillet mais
globalement les universités françaises
sont dans un état pitoyable
sur le plan sur le plan tout simplement
des locaux effectivement il ya des
problèmes de chauffage et puis plus
généralement sans parler de la
logistique les l'aimé rapports
professionnels se sont complètement
dégradée on est dans une automatisation
avec on est gouverné par des outils
numériques type hyper planning etc il
n'y a plus de rapports humains quasiment
tous tout passe par des espèces de mails
automatiser les gens sont atomisés et
les chercheurs enseignants chercheurs
n'ont plus du tout le temps de faire le
leur recherche puisqu'ils sont
complètement phagocyté par des tâches
administratives de plus en plus folles
qui vise à nous à nous détruire et quand
ils essaient de faire des cours c'est
tellement éloigné de la recherche qu'à
la limite au bout d'un moment ça finit
par des qcm automatisé et c'est ce qui
est le cas aujourd'hui donc des robots
en fait qui vérifie que que l'impétrant
a bien pu régurgiter les quelques
éléments de contenu qu'on a envoyé à une
espèce de masse voilà donc oui
l'université elle est à terre et c'est
effectivement chahine la question qui se
pose à moi c'est pourquoi j'y reste
ya plusieurs raisons non non ça il est
hors de question que ce soit un
sacerdoce façon d'options disent que
j'insiste vraiment je n'ai aucune
appétence pour quelque chose de
sacrificielle août christique
j'ai la tendance on a tous on a tous
quelque part quand on est un peu des
voix et plus ou moins elle existe en moi
mais il est hors de question qu'elle
prenne le dessus et il est hors de
question qu'elle prenne le dessus pour
mes camarades donc c'est pas du tout ça
c'est juste que factuellement
effectivement ça me garantit de pouvoir
me loger quelque part etc mais pas
seulement j'aime mon métier
profondément j'aime les étudiants les
la fan transmettre voilà apprendre
beaucoup d'eux non seulement je leur
apprends des choses mais ils
m'apprennent énormément donc ça j'y
tiens beaucoup vous aimez votre pays
non je finis sur l'université et je
pense que même si elle est extrêmement
malade profondément abîmée je ne suis
pas prête à la halle enterré voilà je
considère qu'il ya peut-être encore des
universités ici ou là qui survivent qui
font de belles choses il ya des petits
miracles qui se produisent mois dans les
formations dont je m'occupe c'est le cas
et que peut-être que même si mon
université actuellement va extrêmement
mal peut-être qu elle renaîtra de ses
cendres si on se mobilise dans quelques
temps donc j'ai pas encore abandonné le
navire et je suis je suis dans une
position de repli puisque tout est
hostile mais mais je ne vais pas
abandonner maintenant à l'université à
son opposition aux plissés très mauvais
non mais de fait je vais pas si vous
voulez investir dans une université qui
par ailleurs
dondon si vous voulez toutes les
instances dirigeantes dirige tous leurs
efforts pour finalement nous empêcher de
travailler à envoyer un moment bon par
moments il faut être raisonnable et se
dire là on met son énergie un peu de
côté sur ce dossier et ont investi
ailleurs voilà du soul ou lors de la
guerre non je vous conseille le chapitre
sur les terrains de guerre
et surtout le terrain de mort
question d'internet est ce que vous
aimez votre pays
[Musique]
oui
comment
comme je l'aide par exemple
je les dis un peu tout à l'heure quand
je dis que je
trouve très intéressant de cette idée
républicaine j'ai envie de voir ce que
ça veut dire de ces donner un contenu à
ça dans mon travail c'est ce que
j'essaie de faire je suis attaché à
l'université française ah voilà c'est
donc c'est à toute sorte d'héritage dans
de ce pays auquel je suis attaché oui
question internet c'est ce que l'arrêt
de consommation de masse est une
solution
l'arrêt de consommation de masse
est-ce que ça va être de faire de la
fast fashion paraître de consommer des
merdes made in china on arrête de
consommer pour consommer on arrête de
changer de voiture pour changer de
voiture on arrête en fait de cavale et
de cavale et de cavale est certes mais
après comment enfin si vous voulez
c'est quand même très compliqué par
exemple de garder sa voiture en ce
moment
voilà le problème il est là c'est à dire
que c'est pas seulement des individus
consumériste dégénérés qui se jettent
sur les nouvelles voitures les nouveaux
etc c'est qu'en fait il ya un système
technique et un système réglementaire et
un système politique qui met tout en
oeuvre
pour par exemple obliger un
renouvellement perpétuel du parc
automobile et là c'est fait maintenant
au nom de l'écologie et au nom de voilà
donc
ces complexes c'est à dire moi je suis
d'accord avec ça je suis d'accord mais
c'est un programme projet politique il
faut il faut instruire cette question
politiquement c'est pas je reviens
histoire du colibri c'est pas moi tout
seul qui met bien bon j'arrête avec ça
je change d'esthétique oui on fait tout
le monde le fait de passer de d'une
vision le low cost a une vision plus
locale et sert à tout le monde les gens
qui peuvent le font très bien mais c'est
politiquement qu'il faut organiser ça
pas individuellement qu'est ce que vous
pensez de la
deux groupements de militaires de
généraux qui ont écrit
une lettre ouverte aux couleurs de monde
pour dire qu'il avait le feu à la maison
c'est un signal catastrophique qui nous
rappelle qu' on est au seuil peut-être
de d'événements
désastreux en fait c'est dramatique en
fait mais c'est pas du tout étonnant
c'est le mot
on a déjà un gouvernement aujourd'hui
qui met en place une politique d'extrême
droite sur beaucoup de dossiers et qui
valide l'extrême droite sans arrêt
voilà donc à partir de là il faut pas
s'étonner que l'on bascule dans une
extrême droite alors officiel assumé qui
prennent le pouvoir mais bien sûr
les militaires en question ne se
revendique pas de l'extrême ou est
certes
à dire quand vous en êtes vous pour dire
les choses clairement quand dans un pays
il ya des risques permanents de
mutinerie de la police
et de sédition d'une partie
de grands généraux etc c'est quand même
que vous pouvez vous poser des questions
aux tirs les percuteurs des
manifestations officielles connaît des
militaires vous avez des questions à se
poser sur la suite c'est à dire que
effectivement
la sédition est à l'ordre du jour quoi
le régicide aussi
j'en sais rien je suis pas j'ai pas de
donner des rg pour savoir si mac roger
side
c'est de tuer un roi donc en
l'occurrence je comprends dans votre
question est ce que est ce que tel ou
tel
président serait
susceptible d'être assassiné j'en ai
absolument aucune idée je connais pas
l'état des forces des forces de sécurité
des
si je vous dis sortir les fourches je
vous fait penser à quoi
pas grand chose
si ça me fait penser à quelque chose qui
m'a profondément déplu au début du
mouvement des gilet jaune
qui était le commentaire suivant oui oui
c'est une jacquerie
voilà à quoi ça me fait penser c'est à
dire on utilise un terme totalement
archaïque pour se rassurer en se disant
ouhlala c'est pas quelque chose qui
concerne notre monde d'aujourd'hui c'est
une espèce de résurgence de l'ancien
régime donc la fourche c'est pareil plus
beaucoup de gens je connais peu de gens
qui qui travaillent encore à la fourche
il y en a mais bon ça fait très mal au
dos c'est quand même pas l'outil quel
vent en poupe en ce moment donc parler
de fourche c'est vraiment quelque chose
d'archaïque et c'est une manière en fait
de deux disqualifiés
en fait
de disqualifier
la révolte sociale qui gronde de
légitime de mettre dans une 15 qui
rassure en fait qui est sûr qu'ils les
commentateurs de télé là qui rassure
ceux qui envient que l'ordre en place
perdure parce qu'ils trouvent que ces
purs à sion
il ya un attachement très puissant à
l'ordre en place qui n'est pas un ordre
qui évidemment un chaos est en désordre
mais beaucoup pour leur tranquillité
sont prêts à pactiser avec tout ça parce
qu'ils considèrent que sinon c'est le
chaos et donc on va soit en se projetant
dans l'avenir soit en se projetant dans
du passé archaïque tout faire pour des
potentialiser en fait toute forme de
contestation
réexpliqué
façon succincte ce qui était la
jacquerie un sou qui ne savait pas
c'est sous l'ancien régime le fait que
en fait il y avait des problèmes
récurrents de famine etc les paysans
étaient donc écrasé par les prélèvements
et donc il y avait constamment des
secousses quad était révolte paysanne
qui quelque part un peu dans cet
imaginaire la du terme disqualifiante
jacquerie ne me n'ai jamais rien fait
au fond c'est sale c'est que ça mène à
rien c'est et voilà c'est du cio que
vous ce qu'on entend aussi aujourd'hui
quand on parle de grogne jeu parce que
vous que ça vous évoque ce terme
bien sûr c'est en fait moi il m'arrive
régulièrement de participer à des
mouvements de de mode et mobilisation
sociale contre tel ou tel dispositif par
exemple la dernière fois c'était contre
le projet de réforme des retraites que
pour l'instant nous avons fait échouer
pour l'instant non mais il faut le dire
parce que on ne t'y on ne dit jamais
assez
on ne dit pas quand on a gagné mais
alors là pour l'instant on a gagné c'est
à dire que le projet de réforme des
retraites bruno le maire a dit qu'il
allait le remettre sur la table et il a
tout de suite été contredit par d'autres
membres du gouvernement disant c'est
impossible c'est vraiment pas le moment
pour l'instant on a gagné je vous dis
pas que c'est une victoire définitive
évidemment puisque je vous dis je suis
très inquiète sur sur l'avenir mais je
vous dis que pour l'instant on a on a
bloqué la chose est bien quand on a fait
ce travail qui a été un vrai travail
social et politique qui a été très
puissant sinon on l'aurait pas bloqué
on parlait de nous en ces termes de la
grogne dans la rue
c'est exactement la même chose c'est une
manière de alors la cepal archaïque
c'est la bestialité de disqualifier une
contestation démocratique en la
renvoyant à une animalité où la
psychiatrie zonk les jugements en la
pathologie sort effectivement
question internet de nickel miquel qu'il
est la différence entre l'extrême droite
et la droite et entre la droite et la
gauche bah c'est effectivement
compliquée puisque la droite dite
républicaine ne l'est plus depuis
longtemps elle n'est absolument plus
républicaine est par contre elle parle
de république en permanence mais pour
trahir l'idée républicaine et elle
reprend les thèmes de l'extrême droite
elle les populariser elle joue avec le
feu on en a l'exemple l'a récemment avec
toutes les dernières déclarations de
xavier bertrand inquiet qui disait mais
qui reprend en fait
qui reprend des thèmes de marine le pen
pour faire bien voir de cet électorat et
c'est donc bon c'est pas très original
ça fait très longtemps que que quand on
voit ça à l'oeuvre on peut remonter ya
pas très longtemps avec je vous renvoie
à la rhétorique de sarkozy déjà c'était
ça donc on a une droite qui se dit
républicaine et qu'il n'est absolument
pas et qui popularise l'extrême droite
en pensant naïvement qu'elle va
récupérer la mise alors quand elle ne
fait que qu'elle ne fait que renforcer
son adversaire et on a une prétendue
gauche qui en fait reprend le discours
de la droite donc le programme de la
droite néolibérale depuis très très
longtemps que dans l'est des socialistes
sur le soutien des écologistes aussi
regarder le regarder les déclarations de
yannick jadot qui a déjà dit que nous
c'est une politique de droite clairement
donc on a une gauche qui est en fait à
droite et qui est même de plus en plus
en train de tenir un discours d'extrême
droite puisque on a des candidats à la
présidentielle qui défendent par exemple
l'idée tenez vous bien que les
universitaires sont responsables de
l'assassinât de samuel pâtit islamo
gauchistes c'est ça oui nous avons des
gens comme manuel valls ou agde anne
hidalgo des équipes du helmholtz je sais
mais il est là il a existé puis là ils
essaient de revenir nous avons des gens
comme annuel et que manuel valls ou anne
hidalgo qui n'hésitent pas à considérer
que si on en est arrivé là c'est parce
qu'elle l'islamo gauchisme dans les
universités
donc si vous voulez c'est que cette
cette rhétorique c'est une rhétorique
d'extrême droite parce que la conclusion
de cette rhétorique c'est que si je
prend le pouvoir en pensant cela il faut
donc organiser des commissions pour
contrôler le caractère républicain des
travaux des chercheurs
et là c'est ce que fait la grèce en ce
moment vous avez un une droite
extrêmement dur qui est installée en
grèce en ce moment c'est ce qu'ils font
ils ont mis l'université l'austérité de
2011 d'autres cas ont alors dit merci
mais là exactement vous avez raison mais
là précisément il s'agit soyons précis
de 2 se met en fête la peur dans le rang
des universitaires en mettant en place
un contrôle en fait des recherches donc
il n'y a plus de liberté académique il
faut quand même que vous ayez en tête
que les gens comprennent bien qu'il ya
des membres du parti socialiste qui sont
d'accord avec çà
c'est quoi le parti socialiste
ça a été un parti important qui
aujourd'hui est complètement
qui périclite complètement mon émission
ces faits qui s'est fait
démasquer ou fait non c'était une
coquille vide depuis le départ mais pas
se dire ça oui effectivement c'est
devenu une étiquette extrêmement
embarrassantes
déjà voté parti socialiste est ce que
j'ai déjà voté or ben oui bien sûr
oui j'ai j'ai beaucoup voté moi donc
j'ai voté contre la droite dès que je
pouvais oui j'avais un vote très très
banal quoi une grande très conventionnel
n'ont jamais voté pour benoît j très
sympathique mais j'ai pas voté pour lui
en fait j'ai pas jeu pour des raisons
accidentelle
incompréhensible je n'ai pas voté depuis
plusieurs années
je pense que c'est un fait à chaque fois
que j'ai voulu voter soit ma carte était
bloquée non mais c'est très bien c'est
très étrange soit ma carte d'électeur
j'étais pas à jour soit on dit non non
j'ai des trucs ou alors un jour je suis
venu un scrutin il était déjà passé un
scrutin local fabre est je pense que
j'ai des problèmes depuis quelques temps
pour voter mais j'ai tout mis au carré
je peux rassurer les citoyens qui sont
qui sont très attachés au vote qui
considère que c'est un devoir c'est au
lecteur je suis maintenant inscrites sur
les listes électorales et
et je suis absolument résolu à voter
pour toutes les prochaines élections est
ce qu'il fout tendre la main
aux électeurs d'extrême droite est-ce
qu'il faut essayer de les comprendre où
il faut simplement être dans le rejet
systématique ne pas leur donner la
parole ne pas les écouter
ou pas
essayer de les comprendre j'ai fait
souvent parce que j'ai souvent discuté
avec des gens qui me disaient moi j'en
ai marre je vote marine le pen qu'est-ce
que vous avez compris bah j'ai compris
oui je peux comprendre la colère mais je
je je trouve que là le saut et le somme
apparaît incompréhensible
en jeu non je donc j'ai patiemment
gentiment et sans m'énerver à chaque
fois expliqué que que je voyais pas le
lien logique entre eux la colère que je
comprenais très bien et donc je vais
voter pour quelqu'un qui va persécuter
les plus faibles qui va persécutés et
chercheurs qui va persécuter les
enseignants qui va précipiter le pays
dans la ruine et et voilà donc
je non ça je ne le comprends pas je le
pense que je ne comprendrai jamais
nicolas dupouy nos premiers ministres ça
vous inspire quoi
c'est extrême droite au pouvoir
l'âne plus
question internet est ce que le général
de gaulle en 1940 et s est dit sue
non je pense pas il est entré en
résistance ça n'a rien à voir moi je
vous remercie enfin je remercie 7
cet auditeur parce que vraiment vraiment
c'est important parce que ça me permet
de dire une chose à laquelle je suis
profondément attaché il faut distinguer
la sédition et la résistance et le grand
problème aujourd'hui c'est que les gens
ne connaissent pas ces distinctions et à
partir du moment où vous entré en
résistance il vous accuse d'être
séditieux et précisément c'est pas la
même chose parce que quand vous entrez
en résistance c'est au nom de l'unité
d'un collectif quand vous entrez en
résistance ça peut être par exemple si
on prend des exemples
historique ça peut être pour la défense
de la république
là dans le cas cité et donc c'est le
contraire de la sédition la sédition
c'est
en fait la désunion absolue est la
logique elle et tribales c'est à dire
que chacun part pour lutter avec sa
tribu contre les autres tribus et la
logique c'est ultime c'est la guerre
civile vous n'avez pas le mot communauté
effectivement j'ai pas de beaucoup
d'attachement à ce terme effectivement
je vous dis non je ne suis pas une
adversaire résolu de ce mot je le trouve
beaucoup sous la plume de dieu oui c'est
normal il est américain et il parle de
communauté
voilà je sais pas forcément
l'adversaire de cette perspective mais
c'est pas la mienne en tout cas
question d'internet la démocratie tel un
système trop parfait pour les hommes
comme d'autres villes
alors tant que je ne dis pas ça il dit
deux choses en gros failli beaucoup de
choses dans la de la démocratie en
amérique c'est long il ya deux tomes il
dit beaucoup de choses mais on va
résumer il dit d'une part que et je
pense qu'il a tort la démocratie c'est
le sens de l'histoire donc de toute
façon nous allons aller vers la
démocratie et c'est comme ça et c'est
pas essayé et c'est la providence il
parle de providence on n'a pas le choix
lui c'est un aristocrate il voit tout ça
d'un oeil un peu inquiet mais il dit à
ses amis aristocrate qu'il faut qu'ils
arrêtent de croire qu'ils vont échapper
la démocratie c'est le sens de
l'histoire ça c'est la vraie chose qui
dit et il le dit dans l'introduction et
toute la suite c'est mais la démocratie
c'est dangereux c'est un enfant des rues
qu'il faut domestiquer et pour ça il
faut donc faire appel au gouvernement
représentatif dont je vous ai parlé tout
à l'heure donc l'idée c'est de
domestiquer la démocratie
c'est à dire pour lui le peuple
parce que c'est un torrent bouillonnant
qui cassent tout sur son passage alors
c'est le sens de l'histoire mais il va
falloir l'endiguer en fait exactement
comme une un torrent dangereux par les
digues du gouvernement représentatif et
donc par des élus compétents etc etc
donc il va mettre en place tout un
trésor de d'imagination de réflexion
pour domestiquer la démocratie et la
démocratiser finalement au fond donc
voila et tocqueville en fait c'est un en
réalité c'est un adversaire de la
démocratie mais qui
construit sa conception des choses au
nom de la démocratie vous en avez plein
d'autres lippmann sur lequel j'ai
beaucoup travaillé ces c'est la même
chose question d'y annick que pense
barbara stiegler de l'anarchisme entre
parenthèses proudhon bakounine
kropotkine fermer la parenthèse comme
solution pour rendre la politique plus
organique à gilles flexibles et moins
mécaniste autorités rigide
distribuer le pouvoir à tous plutôt que
de laisser un seul homme un seul parti
alors distribué le pouvoir a tous fait
refaire que le pouvoir circuler très
bien le problème de l'anarchisme comme
le son nom l'indiqué c'est c'est il ya
un alpha privatif c'est à dire pas
d'arqués pas dark et arqués c'est
indécent ce possible du pouvoir donc
c'est c'est quelque chose qui est un peu
ambivalent et c'est pas ma perspective
est
de même pour le discours sur l'état
soutenu par les anarchistes c'est pas du
tout mon hypothèse de travail mon
hypothèse de travail c'est le maintien
de l'état mon hypothèse de travail je
suis désolé c'est extrêmement déceptif
mais c'est vraiment tout sauf eux c'est
tout sauf originale c'est à dire que je
m'estime
enfin j'estime que le plus raisonnable
et de essayé de tester sérieusement
les hypothèses dont on hérite qui sont
effectivement en france l'idée
républicaine je les ai dit plusieurs
fois la démocratie les institutions de
l'état auquel moi je suis profondément
attachée et donc ça explique pourquoi je
ne suis pas à passer du côté des
conceptions anarchistes de la lutte mais
je comprends je respecte mais c'est pour
l'instant par la perspective ça veut pas
dire que ça ne sera jamais d'ailleurs
question interdite ses coulisses le bouc
gauchisme alors l'islamo gauchisme c'est
une espèce de deux
inventions grotesques de
de différentes personnes c'est venu de
si de là alors en france il ya
un certain tagué fkk popularisé ça peu
importe en tout cas ce terme qui ne veut
rien dire qui est profondément vicieux
puisqu'il joue à la fois sur le mot
islam et le mot islamisme c'est-à-dire
l'islamo gauchisme
c'est à la fois le fait que une gauche
jugée
extrême
pactisent avec les musulmans et ça
suggère aussi
qu'elle encourage l'islamisme et donc
les attentats c'est comme ça que blanc
caire a pu dire que les universités
étaient gangréné par l'islamo gauchisme
et qu'elle était responsable de
de ce qui s'était passé
avec samuel paty et de son assassinat
abominable donc il nous a quand même
accusé nous les universitaires d'être
responsables de cette décapitation ça
n'a ému personne
franchement j'ai pas entendu en fait
dans le pays un scandale exigeant la
démission du ministre
c'est un ministre de l'éducation qui
s'adresse en fait assez personnelle
puisque frédéric vidal et sous sa
responsabilité donc il s'adresse à ses
personnels et les accuse d'être
responsables de la décapitation
abominable dindane leurs collègues donc
si vous voulez c'est c'est quand même
incroyable donc l'islamo gauchisme c'est
ça et le but c'est quoi le but c'est à
la fois évidemment de faire taire les
intellectuels qui travaillent sur le
racisme qui travaillent sur toutes ces
questions et les discriminations en tous
genres mais c'est pas seulement ça c'est
aussi le but ça j'en suis convaincu
c'est de décrédibiliser
une partie de la gauche
et en particulier certains candidats à
la présidentielle bat tous ceux qui sont
pas au parti socialiste ou au temps du
bonheur oui bien sûr donc on a
différents différents
représentant d'une gauche qui se dit
soit radical soit je ne sais pas quoi et
en tout cas le but c'est de les
décrédibiliser en les rendant aussi
infréquentable que l'extrême droite
question internet toujours de rzb est ce
que ce n'est pas l'extrême droite qui
est au pouvoir en france mon ce jour-là
déjà répondu oui il ya effectivement
mais on a en un sens ce j ai déjà
répondu aux
questions internet pour paraphraser un
humoriste connu si vous votez ci voté
servait à quelque chose ce serait
interdite qu'en pensez vous est-ce que
vous voterez en 2022
oui je vois très en 2022
je les ai dit tout à l'heure j'ai donc
fait les démarches pour être enfin
inscrite à nouveau sur les listes oui je
voterai en 2022 1 voulez vous des cons
je ne tiens pas à le dire
je n'ai pas du tout l'intention de
demeurer les sosies punk si vous vous de
baudoin un coup de pouce ou non mais
c'est pas ça mais c'est que pour
l'instant je ne tiens pas à le dire et
peut-être qu'un jour je le dirai mais
pour l'instant nous c'est à dire je
choisirai le moment surtout je le dirai
si je le dis
question du petit arnaud comment
définissez vous le bourg radical que
veut-il dire aujourd'hui
radical c'est ce qui renvoie à la racine
donc radical déjà se veut pas dire
extrémistes je tiens à le dire
radical ça veut dire que on reprend les
choses à la racine ça implique une
reconstruction une refondation et donc
ça implique un travail beaucoup plus
sérieux est beaucoup plus profond
extrémistes ça veut dire autre chose ça
veut dire
voilà aller à l'extrême à la limite du
possible
à la limite de la transgression à la
limite peut-être peut-être
éventuellement basculé dans la violence
donc c'est autre chose la radicalité
c'est quelque chose que je revendique
absolument c'est le fait de penser les
choses de la manière la plus approfondie
possible et de les reconstruire les
transformer
au plus profondément et je considère
d'ailleurs que au fond c'est c'est une
des vertus du travail philosophique
quand on enseigne par exemple l'art de
la dissertation à des élèves on leur
apprend essayer de penser de manière
radicale à avoir une certaine radicalité
dans le questionnement par exemple si on
donne un sujet de dissertation sur
l'état il va falloir avoir une certaine
radicalité pour au fond qu'est ce que
c'est que l'état est au fond est-ce
qu'il faut l'état jusqu'à envisager que
peut-être il ne faille pas la discussion
avec les anarchistes qu'il faut avoir
donc voilà c'est vraiment une c'est ça
la radicalité
voulais rajouter ou question d'internet
dans une société aussi profondément
fracturé que la doutre il y at-il
quelque chose derrière lequel toute la
population puisse s'unir
oui oui bien sûr
tout s'est jamais tout il ya toujours un
reste mais une unité massive autour de
bien sûr bien sûr que c'est possible
l'erreur est de vouloir que voilà espèce
d'union à l'union sacrée d'union absolue
d'unité sans reste donc ça je crois que
c'est le consensus mou oui c'est
fantasmatique et c'est oui effectivement
mais on a vu ce fantasme déchaînée au
moment du premier confinement avec
toutes ces tribunes sur le monde d'après
quelle naïveté de s'imaginer que ça y
est le cursus les gens avaient compris
que la valeur c'était la santé la
solidarité que magic man grâce à ce
magnifique confinement dans lequel nous
entendu enfin les oiseaux nous allions
tous sortir de là unis enfin bon c'était
à pleurer donc effectivement et
effectivement c'est c'est pas possible
mais en revanche on peut construire
des majorités massive mais ça se
construit politiquement
voilà moi je crois profondément à la
politique est ce que vous allez vous
présenter me présenter ou dans politique
non pas du tout
parce que je voulais dit tout à l'heure
j'ai mon métier et je peux pas faire mon
métier qui est d'être à la fois
chercheur et enseignante de faire de la
recherche et de l'enseignement de faire
de la recherche enseignement c'est
beaucoup de choses c'est préparer des
cours former des étudiants formés des
doctorants
je suis une vraie pour faire de la
recherche c'est chercher sur des
matériaux sans rien trouver pendant très
longtemps c'est aussi mettre en forme et
valoriser sa recherche par des livres
des ouvrages participer au débat public
j'estime que c'est un devoir d
enseignants-chercheurs de le faire pour
ça que je le fais et c'est pour ça que
j'ai accepté votre invitation est donc
tout ça c'est un travail à temps plein
je vais pas ajouter à cela des fonctions
politiques c'est tout simplement pas
possible et j'aime trop mon métier pour
pour le quitter pour le laisser ou pour
l'arrêter même même deux ans même 50
sinon hors de question
revenons sur la chine
est ce que vous voulez ajouter quelques
mots sur la chine
un nom
questions sur gamestop
je retrouve malines tout de suite
si je la retrouve aussi de me retrouver
les gars alors ok stop gamestop vous
connaissez la faire
je voulais je vous la résume
trivialement les gens décider de le
faire un pied-de-nez au système
financier ont décidé de prendre le
contrôle d'un titre
qui représentait une charge affective
importante pour une bande de geeks et
justice histoire de leur faire la nique
ils sont amusés à prendre à faire monter
cours de cette action est ce que
si je trahis pas la question qui m'a été
posée est ce que est ce que on peut
administrer correctement une société
comme ça c'est à dire chaque petit
porteur peut donner son point de vue
quand on est dans une société
mondialisée qui va à 100 milles à
l'heure
c'est trop handicapant et on est obligé
de délégués notre pouvoir
la question c'est est ce qu'il peut y
avoir des
des entreprises privées qui est une
certaine autonomie par rapport à ses
rythmes et ses sacs et d'intelligence
collaborative et collective des petits
porteurs d'actions peut arriver de
l'action j'ai dans un système
financiarisé non mais même pas je
connais même pas cette possibilité enfin
j y crois pas un instant partir du
moment où on est dans l'ain dans une
financiarisation non je ne vois pas
connaissez-vous l'idée du mouvement de
désobéissance fertile et arrêt avec le
petit
connaissez-vous l'idée du mouvement des
scouts puissance fertile en gros
s'accaparer les espaces pour les
enrichir les à grade et non je ne
prenais pas
toujours parler
exactement la société bipolariser à
chaque sujet bien mal vrai fou pour ou
contre peut-on encore coupons compter
sur l'intelligence collective
alors
c'est une question bobino compliqué
parce qu'en fait il faut distinguer
la logique
de clivage
manichéen entre le camp du bien et le
camp du mal
qu'on a parfaitement vu pendant un an là
vous aviez d'un côté le bon quand le
mauvais camp bon et qui est la logique
entre autres de d'emmanuel macron mais
il est loin d'être le seul quand ils
vous expliquent qu'il ya d'un côté les
populistes et de l'autre les
mondialistes c'est comme ça qu'il est
venu au pouvoir les populistes et en
l'extrême droite et l'extrême gauche les
mondialistes et en lui et c'est ses amis
ou les gens raisonnables qui vont voter
pour lui au second tour tout est fondé
comme ça en fait sur une logique amis
ennemis
donc si vous êtes
de mon côté vous êtes donc parmi mes
amis mes alliés si vous n'êtes pas de
mon côté c'est donc que vous êtes
du côté des ennemis c'est la rhétorique
de george bush vous êtes avec nous mais
c'est au delà de ça vous avez par
exemple
chantal chantal mouffe et oui cas qui a
beaucoup qui pèsent encore beaucoup
aujourd'hui dans une certaine gauche
et ernesto laclau qui qui s'appuient
là-dessus qu'ils considèrent que le
champ politique s'est structuré par des
clivages type à miami moi je suis en
désaccord avec cette perspective ce que
semble dire c'est tout cet auditeur mais
en revanche je pense qu'il faut assumer
le fait que quand il ya une délibération
démocratique y ait une voix qui se
dégage est une autre voie qui se dégage
en face les deux voies ne sont pas
d'accord donc je suis complètement à
l'aise avec l'idée que tout ne marche
pas par des consensus et que par moments
il ya deux voies qui sont en désaccord
qui s'affrontent mais je refuse qu'on
transforme ce dissensus démocratique est
indispensable à une vie démocratique
avec des gens qui vont voter pour des
gens qui ont voté contre en une relation
amis ennemis et c'est exactement ce que
fait
le pouvoir actuel qui est en train en
imposant cette logique amis ennemis
partout qui est en fait une logique qui
est théorisée par carl schmitt tu le
rappelles un juriste donc qui a qui a
collaboré activement au régime nazi donc
voilà
c'est quand même de là que ça vient au
départ quand on entre dans cette logique
là forcément on entre dans une logique
qui encourage la sédition
c'est pour cette raison que je considère
entre autres entre autres mais ce n'est
pas la seule que emmanuel macron et ses
alliés sont des gens qui sont vraiment
des adversaires de l'intérieur et pick
up parce que ils sont du côté de la
sédition et c'est pour ça aussi qu'ils
ont les universités dans le viseur parce
que les universités sont des lieux où on
peut débattre de manière je dirais pas
amicale sans arriver jusqu'à la philia
d'aristote l'amitié chez aristote de la
cité grecque sans arriver jusqu'à de
telles extrémités de du type amitié
d'une communauté mais simplement le fait
qu'on puisse débattre en se respectant
qu'un corps de citoyens que des citoyens
assemblée puisse débattre ne pas avoir
le même avis en virée à l'invectivé
l'anathème etc il ya des lieux encore
comme ça comme les universités et
précisément où certains médias est
précisément ce n'est pas pour rien si on
est en on est dans le viseur parce qu'en
fait il s'agit d'éliminer tous ces lieux
là qui permettent d'avoir une pensée
nuancé d'avoir effectivement de la conf
ritualité du dissensus sous des formes
parfaitement civile et civilisé et à la
place donc on a on entre dans des
logiques de sédition et de destruction
de de quelque chose comme une cohésion
républicaine quel rapport avec la
violence et dans la résistance est ce
qu'il faut est ce qu'il faut
revenir à nos vieilles traditions
françaises
c'est à dire jeté à terre par terre et
demander des comptes et quitte à
demander des comptes à mettre des en
mettant des têtes sur des piques
ou es ce que vous avez un rapport à la
violence qui dit la violence et la force
des faibles et commence où s'arrête les
connaissances
moi j'ai mon obsession c'est d'essayer
d'éviter la violence
on va pouvoir ah ça j'en sais rien du
tout ça j'en sais rien mais c'est l'idée
l'idée c'est que au lieu qu'on conçoit
acculé à à cette sédition dont je
parlais à ces voix là ah
ben c'est précisément de reprendre ce
que coûtait aux débuts l'hypothèse
démocratique pour que la colère sociale
que je partage soit transformé en autre
chose et que du de le pouvoir circule
bien sûr c'est quoi la différence entre
une révolte et de révolution
le problème de la simple révolte c'est
qu'elle peut comme je le disais tout à
l'heure quand être simplement une sorte
de hockey
répétitif qui ne mènent à rien et quand
on parle de révolte ça peut être
disqualifiant voilà parce que ça peut
être de l'indignation morale une
éruption etc mais sans avenir la
révolution ce qui la définit c'est
qu'elle a elle a un avenir en fait elle
elle modifie complètement le cours de
l'histoire c'est ça une révolution ça
modifie le cours de l'histoire de
manière irréversible ce qui n'est pas le
cas d'une révolte la révolte ça peut
être une révolte morale d'un groupe ça
peut être un mouvement populaire à un
moment mais sans lendemain question
internet que pense-t-elle du pacte
républicain qui se profile entre
parenthèses encore et toujours pour le
second tour
je crois l'avoir dit je crois l'avoir
dit
c'est ce n'est pas républicain le pacte
en question est soutenue par des gens
qui sont en train de détruire la
république en insultant les
universitaires comme étant gangréné par
l'islamo gauchisme en
montant les catégories sociales les unes
contre les autres en détruisant les
institutions républicaines
qui permettent un accès égal à la santé
à l'éducation etc cette chose c'est tout
sauf un pacte républicain comment on
fait pour jouer l'islamisme en france
cet islam politique et girly
j'aimerais bien déjà qu'on fasse
l'histoire de l'islamisme en france ça
me ça me ferait bien plaisir parce que
pour l'instant je trouve que c'est pas
du tout été faite n'a pas du tout été
fait et moi ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que j'ai me suis retrouvé en
algérie
dans le dans le nord est au milieu
pendant deux ans j'ai passé beaucoup de
temps en algérie en plein milieu de la
guerre civile et que je me souviens
parfaitement et je n'oublierai jamais
que mon propre pays c'était en 91 92
c'était le début de la guerre civile a
distribué des visas de réfugié politique
aux islamistes qui avaient décidé de
assassiné
puisque les menaces étaient récurrentes
constante nommé etc les gens que moi je
fréquentais à l'époque donc la france a
distribué des visas aux islamistes a
considéré que mohamed boudiaf qui avait
réussi était revenu dans le pays et qui
avait réussi à transformer à retourner
la jeunesse qui commençait à le soutenir
a considéré que c'était un dictateur ce
qui était absolument pas le cas il
essayait de rétablir le pays sur des
bases justement démocratiques et
républicaines
et d'éviter le désastre de l'islamisme
voilà le la france n'a absolument pas
soutenu le régime de boudiaf elle a
premièrement distribuer des visas à aux
gens du front islamique du salut ais à
ceux qui appartenait à des groupuscules
encore plus dangereux ensuite et ces
gens là ont été installés dans les
banlieues par les pouvoirs publics par
les pouvoirs locaux et le but c'était
d'endormir les banlieues par la religion
pour que ces gens soient bien gardées et
au même moment on a pour que les animaux
soient bien gardées parce qu'on en est
là en fait c'est vraiment de l'idée
c'est de d'avoir un bétail con qu'on va
endormir avec toutes sortes d'opium dont
la religion est bien entendu la
politique de la drogue qui va avec et
ensuite on a
au même moment démanteler toute la
politique culturelle de 2 c de ces
espaces urbains tous les services
publics etc et un très bon documentaire
sur ce sujet qui s'appelle sarcelles aux
polices qui raconte l'histoire de la
ville de sarcelles et qui montrent très
bien comment les élus ont remis les clés
en fait aux dignitaires religieux donc
on a nous même installé tout ça enfin
nous mêmes le les pouvoirs politiques
l'ont fait question d'internet du coup
que pense-t-elle des mouvements et
actions de blocage non violents
organisés par extinction rébellion
alternatiba à une v etc
je ne sais pas ça dépend de
bloquer quoi comment où fameux sitting
2.0
s'asseoir d'une façon non violente non
histoire de faire bien chier qu'est ce
que vous en pensez face à des parents
encore une fois efficace est ce que
c'est plus ou moins efficaces
je vais vous donner un exemple vous
annonçant les noms des deux blocs qui
prennent d'assaut le ministère avec un
cédric ça dépend en fait je n'ai pas si
vous voulez de vision
qu'en dira j'ai par exemple pour ce qui
est du blocage je suis pas pour le
blocage ou contre le blocage ça pour moi
ça ne veut rien dire je vous donne un
exemple très précis vous venez tout de
suite comprendre
pendant des années j'ai lutté dans les
mouvements étudiants
vous savez il ya beaucoup de
mobilisations universités j'ai lutté
pour empêcher le blocage de l'université
parce que j'estimais que bloquer
l'université faire en sorte que les
étudiants n'est plus court mettre des
tables et des chaises partout en fait ça
c'est un bété personnes et l'histoire
récente m'a donné raison la l'université
elle est bloquée depuis un an tout le
monde s'en fiche enfin en l'occurrence
les présidents d'université le ministère
ça lui pose aucun problème en fait
qu'ils aient personnes dans les locaux
qui est pas de cours donc moi par
exemple j'ai toujours été contre le
blocage de dans les mouvements dans
lesquelles j'ai été engagée contre le
blocage des cours le blocage de
l'université j'ai défendu de toute autre
idée l'idée d'une grève active dans
laquelle au contraire on va sur place on
travaille avec les étudiants on investit
les locaux on occupe l'université donc
j'ai toujours été pour une occupation
vivante
forte
d'opposition mais pas un blocage des
locaux mais ça veut pas dire que demain
matin je serais toujours contre ce
blocage après il peut peut-être y avoir
des changements profonds qui font qu'à
un moment le blocage il faut le faire
donc si vous voulez je n'ai pas il faut
pas être dogmatique sur ces questions là
les moyens d'action dans la lutte c'est
toujours ça je reviens à l'image de la
dentellière c'est dans la dentelle qu'il
faut penser les choses c'est là où on
est à l'heure où on est avec qui on est
qu'est ce qu'on fait mais dire décrété
d'emblée que c'est merveilleux d'arrêter
le travail ou c'est merveilleux de
bloquer ou au contraire c'est très mal
d'arrêter le travail où c'est très mal
de bloquer c'est formidable de continuer
les cours où c'est très mal voyez ça
veut rien dire ce sont des abstractions
il faut
à chaque fois pensé ça collectivement là
où on est de manière si tu es c'est pour
ça que je suis pas pour ou contre le
blocage
question intéresse qu'il serait le
candidat politique idéal
je ne pose pas les questions en ces
termes le candidat politique idéal c'est
quelque chose qui me démonte où là c'est
quelque chose qui me déplaît parce que
c'est l'idée que une personne un messi
va nous sauver ça passe ça marchera pas
comme ça
déjà il faut
du terrain c'est un oui mais il faut
sortir de cette attente d'un homme ou
d'une femme providentielle ça marchera
pas comme ça une question du mur
holistique question internet quels types
de chf et emmanuel macron c'est tout
sauf un philosophe il a effectivement
factuellement fait des études de
philosophie
pendant quelques temps il est passé à
l'université paris 10 nanterre
il n'a laissé absolument aucun souvenir
à ses enseignants il prétend avoir fait
un master un mémoire de maîtrise sur
machiavel avec etienne balibar qui n'a
aucun souvenir de lui bon c'est un
étudiant visiblement qui n'a par contre
on imagine qu'il allait toujours à la
fin du cours pour parler avec ses vieux
monsieur pour essayer de se faire bien
voir donc mais il dit voilà c'est
quelqu'un qui kiffent actuellement note
anna n'a absolument aucune
n'a aucun lien avec notre discipline
sinon qu'effectivement il a été étudiant
pendant deux ans ou 20 ans ou trois ans
dans une fac de philo mais nous ça n'a
rien à voir c'est une c grave en fait de
lui avoir présenté comme le président
philosophe c'est extrêmement grave c'est
les médias que
l'épidémiologiste par ailleurs vous
savez qu'il a raté deux fois je crois à
l'école normale supérieure et ou trois
fois et que on paye très cher ce
ressentiment parce que il a un
ressentiment contre les intellectuels
etc qui est immense et quand il les a
convoqués pour une nuit vous souvenez où
il s'est mis alors parlé pendant toute
la nuit et que certains sont venus rampe
et de manière complètement c'était une
sorte de revanche c'est à dire ces gens
qui ont pas voulu de moi voilà c'est
c'est vraiment un personnage dangereux
dans la mesure où beaucoup plus qu'on ne
le croit son ressort c'était évident
chez sarkozy mais en fait là c'est
pareil c'est le ressentiment c'est de
prendre une revanche
et notamment sur les intellectuels
l'université tout ça
que se passerait-il si un à paul et où
bonaparte
reviendrait au pouvoir revenez au
pouvoir là c'est pareil je cette
question pour moi elle
n a pas de sens dans la mesure où rien
ne se répète en histoire jamais napoléon
il est mort et enterré à sainte-hélène
je crois et il ne reviendra pas donc
non qu'est ce que vous pensez des idées
rue vivienne alors c'est quoi le
déjeuner là ou là où tu fait bombance
pendant que les fameux dîner cachait la
wii le tripot où vivier
donc en gros ils ont un
restaurant cacher c'est ça avec des
cartes bleues
oui enfin il payant cash cette histoire
là qui est sorti à quinze jours c'est ça
qu'est ce que j'en pense de tout et si
vous avez fait du dîner où ils resteront
clos gustin
non bien sûr que non vous n'y a pas de
restaurants clandestins à bord doit
enfin être pas que je sache qu du
restaurant non ils sont fermées
il n'y a pas de restaurants comme ça
hein si peut-être des choses vraiment
alors très non il y en a pas même à
paris je je je connais beaucoup de monde
à paris je connais pas de gens qui
fréquentent des restaurants pleins
destin
non mais moi peut-être que vous
connaissez non mais vous me posez des
questions personnelles je vous dis que
moi je suis pas occupé à ça en ce moment
je n'en sais rien qu'est ce que j'en
pense que souley c'est désolant qu'est
ce qui est désolant là-dedans m'a
beaucoup de choses il ya du travail
dissimulé
maintenant est-ce que ça m'a étonnée et
choquée mais pas étonnée toute cette ces
gens n'a pas besoin d'aller jusqu'à ses
dignes en fait on une vie
qui n'a presque pas changé en fait ils
vivaient en fait avoir en vase clos il
était déjà servi par des domestiques ou
livrés il sait déjà qu'ils vont pas dans
les magasins ils vont pas au restaurant
ces gens là donc ils vivaient déjà comme
ça que ça a changé pour cette nouvelle
manière de vivre c'est exactement la
même chose quand emmanuel macron voix
voit le désarroi des gens il répondu
côté séries en fait vous dis ouais sans
mal pour lui ça ne change strictement
rien donc ils ont effectivement des
soirées tous les ward et voilà prenez un
exemple penser une chose très simple
roselyne bachelot que j'ai visait
expressément dans le tract de la
démocratie en pandémie c'est pas pour
rien rappelez-vous eba rappelez vous de
ce qu'elle faisait au moment du premier
confirmant l avez vous savez là toujours
de très beau rouge à lèvres
elle a toujours un rouge à lèvres très
très voyant l aime bien s'habiller avec
des choses très variées toujours très
beau projet elle a un très beau sourire
il a été très sympathique d'ailleurs
elle allait tous les soirs ou trois fois
par semaine discuter et rigoler en fait
avec des gens dont sur les plateaux sans
masque
en expliquant aux gens que dans toute
circonstance et surtout en un lieu fermé
il faut mettre son masque mais elle en
avait pas
il ya un moment si vous voulez ce qu'ils
disent pour le bon peuple ces gens là ne
s'applique pas ils sont hills excepte en
fait moi effectivement à l'heure où je
vous parle je n'ai pas de masque mais
est-ce que je d'autre comment veux tu
que trois mètres et est ce que je donne
des leçons de maintien aux gens pas du
tout aujourd'hui pas en toutes
circonstances vous devez absolument dans
un lieu clos m masque donc en fait ce
qui se passe c'est qu'on a des tonnes de
gens qu'on voit à la télévision qu'ils
ne mettent pas de masque depuis le début
et qui nous explique que il faut
absolument tout le temps mettre un
masque comment c'est possible ce n'est
pas cohérent donc elle à elle par
exemple mais on pourra citer bien
d'autres passer son temps en fait à
traverser paris à prendre le taxi
j'imagine trois fois par semaine quand
les gens étaient enfermés chez eux et
elles s'ils voulaient laver une vie
professionnelle
elle discutait l'échangé avec ses
journalistes et chroniqueurs elle avait
une vie si vous voulez social
extrêmement bien rempli elle a fait
campagne pour son poste qu'elle a
d'ailleurs obtenu de ministre de la
culture à la même eau par la même
occasion et si vous voulez elle n'a
jamais été confinés donc ces gens là
n'ont jamais été confiné le confinement
ils savent pas ce que c'est on va
plaider des déclarations d'agnès buisan
et bien sûr que vous
quand elle avoue parler trail
déclaration tout va bien tout est sous
contrôle civil et moi jusqu'au dernier
jour avant le confinement pour moi il
n'y avait pas de problème moi si vous
voulez jamais j'aurais pu imaginer que
va un tel déni au niveau des autorités
sanitaires j'ai participé à un forum
santé avenir à bordeaux il y avait
toutes les huiles de du monde sanitaire
de bordeaux il y avait le dg du chu et
tout le monde était là tout on était là
pendant trois jours on a parlé de santé
c'était je crois le 5 6 mars le moment
où macron disait il faut aller au
théâtre ne changeait rien à vos
habitudes de vie
nous pendant ces trois jours on n'a pas
parlé une seule fois de ce virus chinois
j'avais le directeur général du chu le
directeur de la rs on était 80 dans la
salle il y avait des élus il y avait
tout le monde était là personne n'a
parlé de ce virus était pas du tout
problème pourquoi c'était pas le
problème parce que tous les systèmes d'
alerte nous avait dit il ya rien donc
moi si vous voulez j'ai fait confiance
et je le raconte dans le tract moi j'ai
parfaitement fait confiante j'ai
commencé à comprendre qu'il y avait un
problème quand j'ai reçu des mails
confidentiels comme je travaille dans
les milieux de santé de des milieux
d'anesthésistes etc qui disait le
gouvernement cache la vérité il va y
avoir peut-être des dizaines de milliers
de morts
là j'ai commencé à dire comment c'est
possible on démêle que j'avais pas du
tout à lire qui m'ont été transmis c'est
dans le milieu en fait des chercheurs là
en l'occurrence pour ce qui me concerne
c'était à bordeaux le milieu de l'as des
scientifiques qui était lié à des labos
que les informations sur les projections
ont commencé à circuler
personne n'en parlait nulle part et dans
le milieu de l'art et animations etc
c'est tout et dans certains milieux de
santé publique mais si vous voulez on
n'était absolument pas prévenu est
effectivement agnès buzyn a joué un rôle
de rétention de l'information mais elle
n'a pas été la seule
la terminale et les complicités de tout
ça ça va être ça a commencé déjà être
établie ça va aller moi on va faire un
procès de sa de gestion cuisse alors sur
le plan juridique je sais pas où ça en
est mais en tout cas c'est en cours très
bon justice je suis en cours de toute
façon c'est en bus que c'est en cours
salomon salomon a falsifié des documents
ont tout et tout est établi vous avez
des preuves par mois mais soutient s'est
passé sur la place publique ses sorties
dans les journaux il ya aucun doute là
dessus
magnifique on
sait quoi c'est une décadence et chacun
défend son petit pré carré si de la
soumission c'est simplement notre
système éducatif qui n'a fait que
sélectionner des gens comme moi j'ai
essayé de déjà essayé d'expliquer les
raisons du déni à plusieurs reprises
j'ai fait un grand entretien dans le
monde pour parler de ça
enfin mars à
j'ai d'ailleurs été très honnête parce
que je pense qu'il faut être extrêmement
honnête en cette affaire en disant que
moi même je n'ai pas du tout vu ce qui
se tramait je n'avais rien vu donc j'ai
essayé d'expliquer pourquoi personne
n'avait rien vu venir dans notre pays en
expliquant que voilà ce type de zoonoses
les gens se croyait exemple c'est de ces
choses qui renvoyait un imaginaire
archaïque salle
asiatique lointain enfin vrai mais pas
seulement c'est aussi parce que pour les
une vision néolibérale de la santé ces
questions là ne sont pas les questions
majeures les questions majeures c'est
l'innovation face aux maladies
chroniques donc tout ça ça n'est pas si
vous voulez dans la manière dont ils
sont programmés pour pour penser les
choses et une fois que il était au pied
du mur et qu'ils ont dû reconnaître
qu'il avait un problème il était
absolument désemparé sur le plan
intellectuel etc et surtout macron a
décidé de tout gouverner tout seul il à
désactiver toutes les institutions
produite par la république pour produire
des avis de santé publique il a fabriqué
un conseil scientifique à sa main tout
ça ça a été documentée jeu le document
aussi et ensuite il a fabriqué quand le
conseil scientifique a commencé à se
rebeller assez rapidement mollement mais
quand même il ya eu du tirage il a
fabriqué un deuxième conseil
scientifique le caire qu'il a vite
abandonné et ensuite il a fabriqué un
cabinet de nothing avec bbva pour
modeler nos comportements et nous
raconter en fait n'importe quoi par
exemple quand on vous dit que les dîners
vous voyez à la télévision avec tous les
petites les les petits powerpoint là on
explique pédagogiquement au bon peuple
ce qu'il faut faire quand quand la
journaliste dit les dîners de peau de
six personnes sont désormais interdits
oh ben ça c'est pas la vérité la vérité
qui sait que personne ne peut vous
interdis en faite de dîners chez vous à
20,36 vous voulez ce qui est vrai c'est
que ce sont des recommandations
on les recommandations de santé publique
sont d'éviter de se réunir chez soi à
plus de 6 ça c'est une vérité et le but
c'est d'essayer de faire comprendre aux
gens que c'est raisonnable et là de leur
faire adhérer à cette mesure mais dire
que c'est interdit c'est fou parce que
si une chose est interdite ça veut dire
que si vous la transgresser vous pouvez
être verbalisés or nous sommes toujours
dans un état de droit certes très peu
démocratique mais un état de droit quand
même et aujourd'hui personne ne peut
entrer dans votre maison pour vous
expliquer comment vous devez vivre dans
votre foyer parce que c'est un espace
privé donc en réalité dire que c'est
interdit c'est très grave et n'importe
quel professeur de philosophie terminal
ou de professeur de droit de première
année devrait expliquer aux élèves et
aux étudiants c'est la négation de ce
qu'est le droit
comprendre ce qu'est le droit c'est
savoir par exemple faire la différence
entre une recommandation la norme dans
une entreprise et une loi et quand on
mélange tout ça il ya plus d'état de
droit c'est la négation de l'état de
droit donc aujourd'hui vous avez un
discours médiatique qui dit n'importe
quoi donc qui vous explique que par
exemple dîner à 7 chez soi c'est
interdit c'est faux et quand ils
reconnaissent que c'est ça leur arrive
parfois dans leurs débats parce que
j'écoute beaucoup à ces débats ce jeu
c'est un peu mon matériau de travail
entre autres quand oui c'est assez
pénible mais bon par le chercheur
choisit pas forcément par par goût et et
plaisir ces objets de travail on est
aussi obligé de se taper un peu de la
matière négative pour
affronter mais effectivement je connais
très très très bien le ce discours là et
donc pour les plus honnêtes d'entre eux
c'est mais de toute façon le
gouvernement va pas pouvoir empêcher
le dimanche les rendez-vous avec la
grand-mère à 12 et dans ces cas là ce
qu'on entend c'est et il faut le
déplorer c'est à dire que le discours
ambiant c'est en finir avec l'état de
droit comme en chine pour pouvoir tout
réglementer y compris ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur des espaces privés je m'en
vais vous demander sur la prochaine
question sur la surveillance de brasse
le fait que récemment l'état est
légalisé la conservation de toutes les
url que vous avez consulté sur internet
et j'en passe et des meilleurs ça vous
inspire quoi qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire
face à ça
quand est-ce que ça va s'arrêter est ce
que c'est une façon de de gérer la
l'élevage de poulets pas ce que je vais
faire une comparaison cesser notre
société ressemble à d'élevage de poulets
il ya une pandémie bat normalement il
faut vacciner tous les âges de poules
restantes comme on a une bande de
branquignols bas on n'est pas capable de
le faire donc on se retrouve dans la
mouise
est-ce que la béquille technologique de
la surveillance de masse de ce ramassage
scolaire numérique
c'est une béquille que le pouvoir va
réellement mettre en place parce que
sinon il va être incapable de gérer les
de se faire poursuivre il reste tout un
tas de choses et ses résidents c'est
évident ces mêmes affiches exprès non
mais c'est clair de le le ministre de la
transition numérique cedrico
ça dit tout c'est à dire que l'idée
c'est de digitaliser numériser toutes
nos activités et le ministre en question
il s'occupa d'un petit secteur ce qu'il
fait est transversale à tous les
ministères donc il s'agit de numériser
l'enseignement il s'agit de numériser la
santé en basculant dans la e-santé de
digitaliser le commerce est légitime et
les plateformes en dépit de leur
protestation et de l'or ils se
présentent comme des chevaliers parti en
croisade contre amazon c'est évidemment
une blague donc c'est légitimer les
plateformes quitte à en créer des
européennes peu importe et et
digitalisées voilà le petit commerce par
exemple donc digitalisées toutes les
activités ce qui permet évidemment
d'instaurer une société de contrôle
automatisé
par la même occasion puisque on pourrait
très bien envisager le numérique
autrement le numérique ça peut être le
lieu du logiciel libre ça peut être le
lieu d'une extraordinaire émancipation
ça pourrait tout à fait c'est une
technique bon qui est pas neutre aucune
technique neutre mais c'est un champ de
force dont on peut s'emparer pour aller
vers plus d'émancipation mais là la
manière dont le numérique et
s'allie avec le pouvoir pour les
pouvoirs politiques dominants c'est
évidemment pour une mise au pas mais
c'est pas du tout nouveau jeu les 10 à
l'université par exemple les outils
numériques nous détruisent depuis
longtemps c'est par exemple
l'administration est maintenant
entièrement gouverné par des logiciels
numériques qui sont opaques et qui nous
rendent tout impossible on a plu par
exemple la possibilité de déplacer nos
cours d'aménager les choses de
transformer notre emploi du temps on n'a
plus la main sur rien il faut toujours
passer par des logiciels qui nous gèrent
qui nous qui sont des pointeuses qui
vérifie qu on est là à tel endroit et on
est en fait dans une logique de
contremaître il faut aller voir des
personnels administratifs qui parfois
bien souvent contre leur volonté ils
sont pour rien mais se retrouve dans une
position de contremaître donc ces outils
sont
servent au fond à mettre au pas
standardisé normalisé contrôler et
réduire les coûts rationaliser et
optimiser donc de manière massive et je
pourrais le montrer très bien aussi avec
la santé connectés
qui transforme donc là les questions de
santé publique en un marché de la santé
absolument considérable oui un marché
considérable mais pas seulement la date
a aussi des appareils qui permettent
l'auto connexion et puis la
transformation du patient c'est un show
sur lequel je travaille depuis très
longtemps non
non la hausse allant là où c'est
intéressant c'est que justement en
france c'est ça qui est intéressant on
dit pas client et ça m'intéresse
maintenant mais ça m'intéresse justement
par rapport à ce que je faisais sur le
néolibéralisme et le rapport à l'état on
continue à parler d'usagé de citoyens de
responsabilité citoyenne et c'est là où
ça devient particulièrement pervers en
fait donc c'est à l'intérieur d'un
système qui se dit public avec des
institutions républicaines à l'intérieur
d'un discours qui se dit républicain que
on permute tous les signes c'est ça qui
se passe donc pour revenir à ce patient
le patient malade chronique qui est pris
en main par la santé par la e-santé par
la télémédecine par la santé connectés
par les objets connectés par les data
c'est un patient qui a pour mission
d'optimiser le système sanitaire de
devenir producteur de santé qui doit
rendre des comptes et qu'au bout d'un
moment dont au bout d'un moment on va
conditionner la prise en charge au fait
qu' il est il et jouent le jeu donc
l'idée d'une prise en charge de tous les
patients tels qu'ils sont et derrière
nous pour elle est en train de devenir
une idée du passé et ce qui se met en
place c'est la sélection des bons
patients et l'élimination des mauvais
donc avec un modèle qui n'est pas
exactement le modèle américain
clairement mercantiliste un marchand
c'est un modèle qui est qui et qui ce
qui se décline avec le langage de l'état
avec le langage delà des politiques
publiques avec le langage de la santé
publique avec le langage de la
citoyenneté
et c'est là où il faut apprendre à
décrypter ce qui se passe est en tout
cas le numérique est l'un des leviers
effectivement question internet
vis-à-vis de sa position sur le
sacrifice
et l famille lien avec la thèse de rené
girard selon lequel laquelle la violence
est inévitable dans une société parce
qu'il est dans la nature humaine de
désir de désir et de façon mimétique ce
qui crée de la rivalité donc de la
violence qui doit se déverser quelque
part le tout contre un plus en train
plutôt que le tout à le tous contraints
plutôt que le tous contre tous alors je
connais un peu les thèses de rené girard
je ne suis absolument pas d'accord parce
qu'en fait je ne crois pas du tout qu'il
y ait
une nature humaine qui nous prédisposent
de manière figé à ceci ou cela je
m'intéresse beaucoup aux philosophes qui
sont naturaliste et qui veulent
réfléchir
nietzsche du oui donc les philosophes à
partir desquels je réfléchis avec
lesquels j'ai pas forcément d'accord
mais avec les à partir desquels je
réfléchis donc moi je comprends ce
naturalisme c'est à dire l'idée de
réfléchir sur l'homme depuis
son inscription dans dans la nature dans
le lien à l'animalité dans le lien aux
impulsions à l'affectivité à la
sexualité ya pas de problème avec tout
ça très bien simplement s'imaginer une
fois qu'on a dit ça que on sait ce
qu'est la nature de l'homme au sens de
son essence et que par exemple l'homme
serait bon par nature ou ou méchant par
nature ou violent par nature ou dans par
nature dans la rivalité non en fait
c'est malheureusement j'en suis désolé
mais beaucoup plus compliqué que ça et
je crois que effectivement il ya un legs
naturel nous sommes ces deux cellules
nous sommes faits d'impulsion nous avons
au début de notre vie quand on arrive au
monde et on a en fait des restes
instinctif effectivement qu'ils vont
vite régresser comme par exemple
instinct de succion qui va pas pour pour
l'allaitement et qui va pas durer bien
longtemps donc on a on année on a on a
effectivement
voilà des dispositions
qui nous rappelle qu' on est inscrit
dans l'animalité
considérer qu'il faut se penser à partir
d'un autre monde qui serait le monde des
idées etc me semble complètement fou et
fo mais une fois qu'on a dit ça l'animal
humain du fait de sa néoténie du fait
qu'il est là revers qui n'est pas bien
fini du fait que voilà tout ça ça a été
largement étayée par l'anthropologie etc
il est
essentiellement socialiser et donc ça va
passer par la culture et donc le
discours de rené girard ne va pas parce
que
ça dépend de la société dans laquelle
ont grandi donc non
question attendait qu'il médias
conseiller joue
quel média je conseille alors je
conseille d'abord
vraiment de lire les grands médias les
médias
qui ont pignon sur rue qui sont connus
je pense que c'est extrêmement important
de commandes y lire le journal
lire les journaux plutôt et de regarder
la télévision journal voilà je pense que
c'est très important que les gens lisent
les journaux et regarde la télévision
qu'ils essaient de voir ce que les
autres voient alors c'est très difficile
parce que on n'a plus le phénomène du
20h ou
on avait un public qui massivement
regarder tout le monde à 20h la même le
même journal etc ça s'est un peu on va
dire ça c'est même j'aime bien dire
presque tribalisée c'est à dire qu'il ya
des des groupes des tribus etc mais
quand même il n'y a pas besoin d'avoir
fait de longues études de sociologie
pour voir que
tel tel et tel télévision elle a
beaucoup d'audience tel et tel journal
être élu est encore très lu il suffit de
regarder les chiffres il ya encore du
des tirages sur internet tel ou tel
journal est très lu il ya les médias
alternatifs comme le vôtre et c'est pas
très compliqué de voir les audiences
sont eux se renseigner et donc il faut
surveiller un peu tout ça pour essayer
de ne pas rester dans son point de vue
et celui de sa tribu ou deux c'est toute
sa communauté ou de sa bande de copains
mais d'avoir une vision plus globale qui
sera jamais à temps sur violence pour ça
ah oui bien sûr qui sera jamais qui sera
jamais une vision évidemment exhaustive
voyez synoptique ce qui serait celle de
dieu mais qui sera quand même l'effort
pour essayer de voir d'autres points de
vue c'est fondamental tout ça comment
vision à 360 j'ai pas je rejoue donnerai
pas de chiffres mais en tout cas faire
cet effort et moi ce que je constate et
ce qui m'inquiète beaucoup c'est que les
beaucoup d'étudiants pas tous mais
beaucoup d'étudiants et notamment les
étudiants mobilisés ne sont même pas au
courant de ce qui se passe dans les
actualités nationales ne regarde pas il
faut les comprendre ils ont des jeunes
boxeurs jamais je leur ai mangé ils ont
du mal je les comprends très bien du
prochain pleut manche simplement je
pense que c'est fondamental de se tenir
au courant de ce qui se passe aussi au
niveau national même si c'est dur à
saisir je l'entends mais c'est
fondamental parce que l'idée c'est
d'arriver à essayer de recréer un espace
public donc d'éviter une forme de de
sédition cognitive où chacun est en fait
dans sa tribu donc c'est fondamental
cette affaire est ce que il faut se
faire violence oui parce que en fait
l'idée n'est pas d'aller suivre ses amis
ce n'est pas de follow et ses friends
pour
paraphraser le vocabulaire des réseaux
suivre être followers de ses amis de ça
ça nous vient des américains bon voilà
donc ce n'est pas ça qu'il faut faire
bien sûr qu'il faut avoir des camarades
de lui des complices des amis des
proches une famille très bien mais il
faut faire de la politique et donc il
faut essayer de faire le tour de la cité
et faire le tour de la cité c'est
effectivement en prendre sur soi à
supporter elle dit des discours qu'on
n'a pas forcément envie d'entendre mais
c'est sa habiter dans une cité commune
donc effectivement mois avec une
certaine limite sur le plan parce que je
tiens aussi à ma santé effectivement je
m'insurge it de haut niveau hebdomadaire
des doses assez conséquente de discours
de gens avec lesquels je suis pas
d'accord mais voilà je te je pense que
c'est extrêmement important
voilà de ne pas quitter ce terrain là et
de faire face ssq ensuite ce qui me
permet de démonter leurs arguments parce
que je les connais
et ça peut être des arguments de gens
très sympas qu avec lesquels finalement
je vais être rallié plus tard enfin
voilà il n'ya pas la logique ami ennemi
c'est pas ça c'est faire le tour de tous
ses points de vue conflictuelles
parfois même qui vont jusqu'à des choses
des véritables dangers pour la cité là
je vous en ai je vous ai énuméré un
certain nombre de gens que j'estime
profondément dangereux à commencer par
ceux qui sont actuellement au
gouvernement
mais le but c'est de ne pas en arriver
là c'est à dire d'être capable d'assumer
des désaccords des conflits
intellectuelle des désaccords sur la
méthode d'être capable d'aller loin dans
le désaccord est de s'en remettre d'être
capable d'affronter des conflits sans
que ce soit une guerre quand vous sur ce
désaccord question internet l'université
n'est t'elle pas une salle d'attenté
avant la découverte du chômage
alors les études sociologiques dont on
dispose aujourd'hui sont unanimes plus
vous avez fait des années d'études
supérieures plus vous êtes protégé
contre le chômage donc le choix plus ou
moins conscients d
des citoyens d'aller vers l'enseignement
supérieur parce qu'ils y vont
massivement les familles vont
massivement vers l'enseignement
supérieur et ses diverses formes il ya
plein de formes d'enseignement supérieur
l'université n'est pas la seule mais
l'université ses massifs c'est quelque
chose en fait assez raisonnable en gros
plus votre enfant aura fait de longues
études - il sera il risquera d'être sans
emploi
donc 7 en fait j insiste là-dessus parce
que c'est une contre vérité à laquelle
malheureusement crois beaucoup
d'universitaires qui s'imaginent qu'en
fait ils conduisent leurs étudiants chez
pôle emploi mais c'est pas vrai c'est
pas la réalité on devrait être beaucoup
plus fier de ce qu'on fait on ne conduit
pas les étudiants au désastre on leur
donne en fait toutes sortes de capacités
ensuite qui vont leur servir avec de
fait leur serre dans le monde du travail
donc c'est en fait une manière de
disqualifier une fois de plus
universités que ce discours sur la fac
mène au chômage
que pense-t-elle des réunions double
mixte
les réunions non mixtes
écouter honnêtement ça m'intéresse
absolument pas que
des femmes venues discuter entre elles
qui ont des problèmes qu'elles ont vécu
en tant que femme que des personnes
victimes de racisme va y discuter entre
elles de mécénat aucun problème je m'en
fiche complètement en fait ça me semble
me dérange pas du tout enfin je vous
fait je trouve
délirant qui ait eu ces débats en fait
je trouve ça délire complètement
délirant c'est un non sujet et je ne
suis absolument pas étonné qu'ils aient
lieu tout ça sert à nous diviser a
disqualifié
les mouvements de gauche l'émouvant
mobilisés ça n'a pas d'autres
fonctions et il faut surtout pas rentrer
dans ce piège et est rentré dans cette
discussion ça pour moi strictement aucun
intérêt
est ce que vous voulez qu'on aborde un
sujet en sang en particulier
s'est bien passé et
j'ai un peu mal aux yeux parce que là la
lumière s'il veut me faire parler fait
très mal aux yeux
est-ce que vous avez trois bouquets un
conseiller d'autres communautés
alors un livre que j'ai commencé à lire
là donc je peux pas me prononcer sur
tout le livre parce que j'ai juste lu la
première section premiers chapitres
c'est penser en chine
de 2,1 folio de chez gallimard qui était
dirigée par anne cheng je crois le
premier texte est absolument saisissant
il s'agit d'un universitaire chinois qui
expliquent
le projet politique de jean ping qui qui
monte qui explique en quoi en fait c'est
un projet
complètement
qui quitte en fait fondée sur un
mensonge fondamental et c'est assez
impressionnant puisque cet universitaire
sept historiens chinois est à shanghai
voilà il
ose comme ça démonte et la politique de
jean ping de manière assez
impressionnante et ça ça m'a l'air
extrêmement robuste ou et 7 cette
analyse alors encore une fois je suis
pas du tout qualifiés pour un juge et
voilà mais je trouve ça extrêmement
intéressant donc oui je conseille cette
lecture
de saute j'ai 24 ans comment faire
comprendre des principes complexe est
essentielle à une jeunesse abrutis jour
et nuit à coups de gaffes âme et
compagnie et qui pour certains sont
diplômés à bac bac + 3 à bac + 5 sans
même savoir à dire poser une simple
division
le sens de cette question c'est que tout
la jeunesse serait essentiellement
abrutissent ça et lui même est jeune et
il trouve que sa génération était
complètement abrutis et il l'est
toujours si si je peux me permettre son
travail
l'idée l'idée de l'auditeur mais est ce
qu'on n'est pas arrivé à un niveau où
les gens sont venus complètement crétin
complètement égoïste complètement bercé
écoute téléréalité débiles mentaux toute
la journée
est ce que le niveau est tellement bas
escale à deux éléments de réponse de
faiblesse psychologique qu la société
induits sur ces gens l'aimaient en
catatonie émotionnel dont on parle d de
la jeunesse de la jeunesse bon moi j'ai
pas je comprends effectivement les
systèmes d'éducation sont tellement
abîmée que effectivement ça abîme
l'éducation donc ça abîme le contenu ça
abîme la formation c'est tout à fait
normal maintenant mon impression de
cette nouvelle génération
c'est qu'elle est quand même sur
beaucoup d'aspects plein de ressources
voyez par exemple les mobilisations sur
le climat qui ont été vraiment massive
voilà donc on a on a dans cette
génération des capacités de mobilisation
et des ressources qui sont un immense
moi il m'arrive alors j'ai effectivement
une vision un peu comme on dirait
aujourd'hui biaisé puisque les gens qui
qui viennent jusqu'à moi sont des gens
qui sont qui ont le bac et qui ont
choisi plus ou moins plus loin parce que
parcours su parfois les envoyer là sans
qui rien demandé à personne mais on va
dire que plus ou moins ils ont mis le
mot philosophie dans leurs choix donc
évidemment c'est pas je n'ai pas devant
moi tout un des exemplaires de toute la
jeunesse de france mais j'ai devant moi
des gens qui ont des parfois un niveau
scolaire extrêmement faible
ça arrive beaucoup et ce que je vois
c'est que quand il ya une prise en main
pédagogique sérieuse et radicales pour
reprendre l'expression tout à l'heure on
arrive à des choses assez rapidement
c'est impressionnant quelqu'un de jeune
il ya une plasticité il ya une capacité
à apprendre et une capacité à faire des
bonds qui est phénoménal si on veut ni
plus aussi aussi mais en tout cas je
pense que quand quand les gens sont sont
jeunes même s'ils ont subi tout ça même
s'ils ont un rapport aux médias que j'ai
un peut esquisser tout à l'heure du fait
qu'il ya de lecture des journaux il ya
plus d gap on regarde plus la télévision
que regarde la grand mère etc même si
tout ceci pose problème on peut faire
encore beaucoup de choses et par
ailleurs sur le niveau général
d'éducation de la population sans parler
de la jeunesse mais plus généralement
mon point de vue et qu'en fait il ya un
niveau d'éducation assez élevé il ya une
demande
de réflexion qui est énorme c'est pas
pour rien qu'on a obtenu que les
librairies restent ouvertes ça c'est
encore une victoire des citoyens de ce
pays qui ont réussi à imposer à ce
gouvernement qui règne de manière
extrêmement rude l'ouverture des
librairies c'est quand même une conquête
il faut le il faut le saluer il ya une
demande énorme sur sur sur les livres
sur les festivals sur assez massif
l'impression que j'ai est plutôt que on
a une population qui est très éduquée
est relativement bien éduqué en tout cas
il ya eu un élève mme en général ça
aussi c'est documenté par la sociologie
du niveau d'éducation de la population
du fait du fait je venais juste de
l'augmentation des études etc et en même
temps moi ce qui me frappe c'est là où
je veux bien dire que le niveau baisse
c'est pour ceux qui ont des
responsabilités qui sont passées on est
passé de responsables institutionnels ou
politiques qui avait un langage châtié
qui était cultivé qui avait voilà toute
une sorte de une véritable formation à
des gens dont on se demande si c'est
possible qu'ils soient élus
voilà où qu'ils soient ré non
tout le monde tout le monde nous voit
très bien de qui je parle c'est à dire
l'essentiel du personnel politique qui
est en vue je parle pas des pertes du
personnel politique à l'ancienne qui
existe toujours et qui continue à faire
tourner les institutions je parle de
ceux qui sont qui sont en vue il ya une
prime à la médiocrité intellectuelle
il ya une prime à la vulgarité il ya une
prime à la malhonnêteté et on a la même
chose au niveau des institutions on voit
maintenant des gens diriger des
universités diriger des hôpitaux mais
c'est proprement consternant donc on a
le niveau intellectuel des infirmiers
des aides soignants des médecins etc qui
est qu'ils aient levé finalement il ya
vraiment une exigence et puis des chefs
pour simplifier je déteste ce terme mais
qui se comporte comme tel qui sont en
réalité inapte inepte inculte et qui
répètent les impératifs gestionnaire
voilà donc c'est affolant et quand on en
est là évidemment c'est ça remet
complètement en cause les principes du
gouvernement représentatif puisque le
pour revenir à notre discussion du début
puisque les principes du gouvernement
représentatif c'est que nos élus soient
les plus compétents les plus éclairés
les mieux élevés les ceux qui parlent le
mieux et c'est hélas on a en fait un
gouvernement représentatif qui marche à
l'envers donc du même coup il est en
crise un mou sur le pince le pass
vaccinatoire occidental
c'est à dire bien pas bien il faut
l'imposer pas l'imposer mais je sais pas
moi je peux comprendre qu'un pays
dans lequel le virus circule pas
n'accepte pas de ressortissants
étrangers sans avoir les garanties
de ceci ou de cela le problème c'est que
le vaccin à l'heure actuelle ne nous
donne aucune garantie qu'on ne
transmettent pas le virus
on commence à avoir pour certains
vaccins des remontées peut-être positive
mais enfin rennais encore peut-être
négatif sur la capacité vous utilisez
dans le tendon d exact du coup voilà
partir dans cette logique alors même qu'
on n'a absolument pas trouvé par ce
vaccin par ces vaccins la solution
thérapeutique qui nous a débarrassé de
de la chose paraît complètement aberrant
j'ai une question d'internet de hassan
une question personnelle
question pour complet pour compléter le
retail de clôture thinker view
quels sont les trois plus belles leçons
qu'elle retient son père et qu'elle
souhaite partager avec nous entre
parenthèses signé un étudiant éternelle
de bernard stiegler fermer la parenthèse
merci
mais je préfère pas répondre parce que
c'est ce qu'il ya pour moi
il manque deux bouquins ah oui de
bouquins
à écouter
que vous dire j'en ai tellement la
formation batave s'est pas par où
commencer est-ce que j'ai fermé les yeux
et imaginez le titre
non je suis désolé j'ai pas j'ai c'est
vrai que ce livre sur la chine voilà je
trouve que ça vaudrait le coup que les
gens s'y penche quitte à polémiquer en
disant que c'est pas
c'est pas la bonne entrée moi ya pas de
problème j'y connais rien donc moi je
suis prête à me faire instruire mais je
trouve que c'est intéressant je pense
que c'est un gros travail qui a été fait
qui a été fait autour de ce livre quoi
donc il faut il faut regarder ça voilà
ses nombreuses non je sais pas un
conseil pour les jeunes générations
bouteiller l'année un conseil sur les
jeunes générations avis vous m'aviez
fait les coûts la dernière je vous
conseille pour les jeunes générations
wiba que les jeunes générations
moi je les appelle à à défendre avec
nous avec ceux qui même si on est très
peu nombreux peu importe même si on
échouera peu importe il faut pas
toujours vouloir gagner il faut vous
faire les choses on verra si on gagne
défendre l'esprit de l'université qu'est
ce que j'appelle l'esprit d'université
c'est le fait que enseigner c'est aussi
faire de la recherche faire de la
recherche c'est aussi transmettre c'est
faire circuler en fait la discussion
démocratique est instruite et éclairé ne
pas avoir peur de la confrontation de du
désaccord pas tout ce que je vous ai dit
tout à l'heure considérez que c'est ça
qui nous forme qu'on se forme tout au
long de notre vie comme ça pas par des
coachings aider management et des
sessions de management et pas par des
cessions de méditation pour déconnecter
et pour recréer une bulle de bien-être
mais qu'on se forment en fait par
l'épreuve démocratique et que ça passe
par l'esprit d'université qui doit
circuler partout de la classe maternelle
jusqu'à l'école d'infirmières en passant
par la fac de médecine en passant par
les stages de formation en entreprise
l'esprit de l'université doit circuler
partout et qu'est ce que c'est que
l'esprit de diversité
c'est l'idée que la jeunesse porte du
nouveau c'est ça que ça veut dire
l'université la jeunesse porte du
nouveau mais elle ne peut exprimer cette
nouveauté que si elle est formée par les
plus anciens et si elle le fait dans un
esprit de recherche avec les plus
anciens dans un esprit de co
construction des savoirs avec de la
méthode avec des disciplines avec des
chants qui sont structurés voilà et je
pense que c'est vraiment quelque chose
qui s'adresse à la jeunesse et que
partout on est on peut être dans un
lycée on peut être dans un collège on
peut être dans un institut dans une
boîte privée peu importe on peut
contribuer à essayer de faire revivre
cet esprit de l'université qui est
aujourd'hui attaquée de toutes parts par
parra stickers merci
[Musique]
e